it is uh 9:15 and we try to start on
time this being veterans committee so at
this time I will uh start with the
Pledge of Allegiance if you would if you
would rise
and I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
of God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all okay welcome to state federal and
Veterans uh we have three bills
scheduled for this morning um I will
tell you that the third one uh the
sponsors asked if we could recess it and
uh reschedule until next week which we
will do so that leaves us with two bills
this morning starting at 9:15 9:16 with
uh HP
1156 uh and we'll go to that in just a
moment um so I do want to say that
unlike some our previous couple uh
hearings where we had ended up with a
lot of folks who wanted to testify and
we did have to uh try to limit the time
on testimony not a problem today um so
uh we have a good number of cards for
this first measure uh so some of you
have asked for one or two minutes up to
10 minutes uh uh so don't feel any
constraints you have plenty of time to
fully uh make your case or or say what
you like us to hear also want to
apologize we have a lot of folks missing
today for different reasons usually uh
we like to have most everybody here for
these hearings um but we have some uh
scheduling conflicts etc etc so uh we
will have an executive session this
afternoon with uh with subs and we'll
have a full house then okay uh to start
off today with uh HB 1156 relative to
public health safety and state
sovereignty uh Prime sponsor is here
representative Granger welcome back uh
thank you for having me I've been
considering getting a tent and just
parking it in the back considering how
often I'm in front of this committee
hopefully I don't wear out my welcome
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee so so this is a nullification
Bill and uh what that means is that it
utilizes the 10th Amendment of the US
Constitution uh to deny State resources
to Federal Pro uh programs um you you
might have if you're in this committee
I'm guessing you probably ran across it
before but just in case you know this
isn't unprecedented this is uh held up
to Supreme Court scrutiny multiple times
uh the standard example of nullification
is when uh States refuse to Force the
Fugitive Slave Act uh this was tested in
PR versus Pennsylvania and since that
case the general principle that the
federal government can't Commander State
resources this is now called the uh
anti-commandeering Doctrine and this is
how various states legalize marijuana
and we've done it a couple times in this
state in other committees and uh you but
nothing of nothing in regards to
specifically the
CDC um so what this bill does is it
prevents the state and municipalities
from enforcing the edicts of the CDC or
the world World Health
Organization so the CDC is part of the
US federal government the World Health
Organization is part of the United
Nations and I don't believe that the
state of New Hampshire should be uh
doing any of their work for them
especially considering uh the heinous
displays we've seen over the last
several years
um so um with with that I would if I
would take any questions about the
legality of the bill as other people
here including Dr cat who came from a
very long way um will be able to cover
the specifics of why it's important to
do this for the CDC and the World Health
Organization in particular I'm open to
questions thank you representative so
I'm going to ask right up front uh is
this largely inspired by the covid
epidemic or the co pandemic and
everything or or there was went with
that yes but there's other factors in
involved as well so uh they they're not
just incompetent when it came to the
Corona virus they also uh so for
instance if you go to the CDC website
and you look up the zika virus they say
that any place that is purple on their
map uh married couples should engage in
uh in in marital processes with um with
prophylactics and um part of the area
that's purple is the entirety of the
continental United States uh just as an
example uh they they do all sorts of
crazy stuff that other people are going
to be able to talk about but the prime
motivator is in fact their response to
the Corona
virus okay so a question uh along those
lines during the uh pandemic there were
mask mandates uh uh all over the place
um some schools had them businesses had
them the state had them for a while if
you recollect in
2020 uh it was uh you know under the
emergency powers that the governor had
um at that time time there were these
mask mandates that were in place so uh
let me ask you about the mask mandate
piece of it I know a lot of folks had
heartburn with that in 2020 2021
um with the with
this with this measure um would that
impact uh local mask mandates uh I know
there's a difference between like a
municipality wanting to have a mask
dayses let me ask you specifically I
live in Lowden so if Lowden had a uh
selectman's meeting and Lowden wanted to
have a mask mandate that required
everyone to wear a mask or or school
board meeting uh which happened we had
Schoolboard meetings and everybody had
to wear mask to go to the school board
Schoolboard meeting so what do you
envision this measure would would this
have impact on local control in terms of
municipalities having mask
mandates I believe I could I believe
that that sort of uh ma local mask
mandate is covered by other parts of law
um that being said I believe the heart
of your question is whether or not
they'll just be straight banned from
doing it because the CDC says it's not a
good idea is that is that
correct sure the C CDC is a federal
operation correct yes so if the
CDC I think they recommend I don't know
that the CDC can mandate if the CDC
recommends masks and a school board
meeting or selectman meeting uh requires
people to wear masks to attend a public
Municipal meeting citing the
CDC
guidance um would this measure which is
U relative to public health and safety
um
so in the analysis line says this the
this bill it's a bill provides that the
uh Center for Disease Control of the CDC
shall have no jurisdiction in New
Hampshire so my my question is I don't
know that they necessarily had
jurisdiction anyway I think they they
they were a not a statutory body they
weren't Congress so if if the CDC made
ma recommended mask
mandates then
the local
municipalities given this HB that we
we're looking at is we're looking at
here the local municipalities could cite
this where this to move forward they
could cite this and say uh CDC we don't
want to wear masks and we're not going
to wear them is is that kind of what
this is about so so when you said that
they cite the CDC as the source of the
mass mandate that would be where I
believe it would would cross if this
build would become law so if a local
municipality doesn't justify their Mass
mandate with the CDC I would still
oppose the mass mandate um but I do not
believe that this would prevent them
from enfor from making their own Mass
mandates they just wouldn't be able to
use the CDC as a justification for it so
if a if a Municipality of some sort um
did not want say say the next pandemic
or whatever uh if a municipality did not
want to have a mask mandate they could
cite this this measure this HB this law
If It moveed Forward they could cite
this and say uh yeah the the CDC wanted
us to wear mask but because of this
legislation uh we're not going to is
that fair to fair to look at it that way
uh right they wouldn't have uh the CDC
wouldn't have uh with this bill in
effect they wouldn't have any excuse to
think that the CDC has legal authority
to command them to have a mass mandate
or anything of that sort okay uh
followup um how about Manchester Airport
uh with Airlines had uh mask mandates uh
nationally would this a bus terminal or
an airport you know if a transportation
company or an airline had mask mandates
uh would this have any impact on that I
uh I don't want to mislead you and so
I'll preface this with I'm not 100% sure
I do not believe so because I believe
that the airports are private however I
don't know if they're totally private um
if I I don't believe it does however I
could be mistaken about
that okay thank you representative I
know I've been kind of peppering you a
little bit uh questions representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question let's say this bill
would pass who would be in overall
control of of deciding uh Statewide
would be in in the state itself and not
not be influenced by The Who or the CDC
who would make the determinations that
somebody should wear a mask or you could
you you should get u a vaccine if we I'm
I'm I'm talking pandemic here I'm not
talking normal
stuff it would be the legislature or
elected
officials so it would be Statewide but
what if a city that thank you for a
followup Mr chairman so what if a city
or several townships decides we're not
going to have a mask I live in
Manchester okay and they say well you're
going to have to wear a mask but if I go
to nashille I don't have to wear a mask
so it would be would it not be a
hodgepodge of wherever you're living is
you decide so if you if you can't if you
don't have to wear a mask in one town
and you go to another town to shop or
something would you have to wear a mask
if that municipality decides that yes
they will enforce whatever well I'd
prefer they just didn't make such uh
edicts in the first place uh but I would
consider that beyond the scope I I don't
think that local municipalities should
have ever enforced a mask mandate for
instance um if if they do that and then
people decide that they don't like
visiting that town and I guess that's on
them and their Selectmen or their uh
local legislative body however they run
it depending on if it's an fp2 or
whatever one more comment sure chairman
thank you
this to me would would be like a
hodgepodge it's it's like you go here
and you got to do this you go there you
don't have to do
that it would be a mowe
so if this were to pass I my personal
opinion would you believe would be that
it should be like a Statewide decision
to whether uh plan A would be instituted
or plan b or whatever would you agree
age with
that I don't have the text of the bill
or references to the bill I believe
there was a separate bill specifically
addressing local mask mandates and I
believe the intent of the bill and I
could be misremembering was to prevent
them from instituting local mask
mandates um I would have supported that
bill um if if you know but uh I think
that would Sol if if that were to pass
and that's not in this legislation if
that were to pass that I believe that
would solve the
problem uh represent
filat thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you prime sponsor uh some there may be
multiple questions related to this if
you would indulge me uh sometimes a bill
or a proposal can have unintended uh
flow on effects uh and here the
suggestion is that the state and its
political subdivisions including but
unlimited to counties cities towns
precincts water districts Etc shall not
engage in the enforcement of of any or
any collaboration with the enforcement
of any requirements mandates
recommendations instructions or guidance
provided by either organization
referencing uh the CDC or the who now it
seems as though much of the discussion
here has censored on uh mask mandates
and covid which seems a natural flow on
from what we've just all experienced
over the last four years which is
incredible that we've all now been doing
this for four years but the World Health
Organization does more than Co and mask
Ates for example would this uh proposal
now say that the state would no longer
be able to discuss or recommend or
recommend the world Heth the World
Health organization's recommendation
that individuals with HIV or at risk of
hvv engage in testing
regularly they wouldn't be able to site
The Who as a source um if they want to
recommend that on their own without you
citing the wh then I believe that would
be fine with the language that's in the
bill now to with respect though they
would also not be able to rec to use the
CDC as the the source for that which
would now be the two prime organizations
in the world as the source for it uh so
where would the recommendation for this
coming from and this is just one example
basically every STI every major
communicable disease every uh disability
one can think of there are
recommendations coming from these
organizations on and now these are
unable
correct representative Massa you're
recognized thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question how
would this be enforced and who would be
responsible it would uh basically be up
up to the citizenry to enforce it and uh
it would probably be handled um in the
in the
courts
people seem to think they
do and and and the reason that's
important is uh because uh a lot of
towns and municipalities were citing The
Who and the CDC as the source or the
authority and said well we have to the
CDC said so and um whether they actually
do or not and whether that holds up to
Legal scrutiny if this is in law they
won't be able to do do that
anymore I I understand your uh
the there are doctors and experts and
all that in the state of New Hampshire
that can have influence on legislator
and
legislators uh therefore I do not
believe that it is taking it away from
doctors um I believe it is taking away
from one or two specific groups of
Highly incompetent doctors and then
putting it in legislators because when
it comes to the medical profession and
any any hypers specialization
you need a you need a sanity check
occasionally with people who are not in
there just to make sure that they're not
just getting caught up in the weeds and
I believe that's a large part of what we
saw during the coron virus response was
people who were very well intentioned
but they went down a rabbit hole and
hyperfocused on their on their one area
of study to the detriment of everything
else and this happens somewhat
frequently so for instance in the Opium
epidemic uh we we saw all these doctors
openly declaring that pain is a Vital
sign and uh then we had a crazy op they
were started prescribing Opus like crazy
but if we had like elected legislators
overseeing that then it's a good check
and that's why the DHHS is responsible
or is overseen by the legislature and uh
you know there's a lot of Highly
competent medical professionals in there
um I believe that history has shown that
the CDC and the who are not competent we
should not take advice from them
it's okay okay you're up thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
doesn't this make it very confusing for
the public as to whom to listen
to the bill does not require the public
to stop listening to the
CDC um it just means that uh the state
and political subdivisions don't listen
to the CDC so I I don't it would be very
confusing oh hey mine's
a very real question that I just
actually thought of which I don't have
an answer to to what extent does this uh
proposal conflict with the First
Amendment and the right of legislators
to be able to consider what information
they please while they are considering
legislation Mr Prime sponsor I do not
believe uh that it uh conflicts um but
uh you have the right to disagree with
me um I I don't think it I don't think
that's an
issue other questions
thank you representative Granger thank
you very much okay moving right to
representative Manion me member of this
committee
uh welcome representative Manion
speaking for the
Bill thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Tom
Manion representing Hillsboro one the
town of pelum uh so uh despite my
dislike of most federal agencies if you
were to ask me in 2019 Tom surely
there's some Bureau that's wholly good
not captured by political interests I
would have said sure probably the CDC we
can keep that one uh fast forward to
February 12th 2021 the CDC released
guidance for the return in-person
instruction for schools that included
massive carve outs allowing for
administrators to use any number of
excuses to continue the damaging remote
learning status quo this was running
counter to widely accepted worldwide
data that showed virtually zero risk to
of the virus to Children it was after
several school systems this was after
several school systems dumps tens of
millions of dollars upgrading HVAC
systems in the FDA Fast Track teachers
to the top of the vaccine release
schedule so the question is why would
the CDC an organization that is claiming
Authority on the science ignore the
multitude of unrefuted studies that
showed the near zero risk to Children
enter a freedom of information request
uh that showed email change between CDC
director Dr relle wilinsky and the
American Federation of teach teachers
the largest teacher Union in the country
what was exposed was a requested
language from a non-scientific lobbying
organization that made it almost word
for word into the official science-based
guidance issued by the CDC this act
delayed inperson learning across the
country for students in some areas for
almost another year we're still seeing
the detrimental effects of this decision
n Nationwide and an entire generation of
children have been damaged by this
collusion of special interests and a
bureau that
shouldn't should have been the most
fact-based one of the entire mess in DC
so if you were to ask me now Tom surely
there's some Bureau you'd keep my
response would be a resounding no and
since we don't have the ability to
dismantle it here from conquered the
least we can do is damage it's going uh
limit its damage going forward please
vote OTP on HB
1156 thank percent would you take
questions if there are any yeah I'm open
to questions okay I I do have a quick
one here uh because you mentioned
education U numerous schools clo closed
uh public schools in particular many
private schools uh parochial schools
Charter Schools stayed open more nashar
is an example among others was closed
for about a year and I believe that that
these schools who closed cited uh the
CDC yes uh and Anthony fouchi is a
rationale for closing down uh live live
learning so where this measure to become
law uh if I read this correctly and this
why I'm asking if if uh the next
pandemic hopefully it'll be far in the
future if ever but if something is what
happened a couple years ago happens
again if a school seeing you mention
learning if a
school wanted to site the CDC as a
reason to close and and they and they go
to remote learning would this law give
uh citizens legal basis to to sue the
school district to reopen is that I I
wouldn't think so uh to me any any
guidance going forward here is is
suspect because we're already seeing we
saw already that this Bureau has been
captured as well by special interests so
regardless of whether they issue this
this guidance or not I wouldn't listen
to it period And I understand that some
people take Umbridge with that but I
don't trust any of these organizations
anymore they're just
captured yeah again my question
sorry basically was if there this were
to be come La could citizens in a city
or a town use this measure as a basis to
sue the school district and require them
to reopen if if the only rationale they
have for closing is a CDC or who
recommendation I mean the schools
themselves can find Outside sources and
if they go outside sources they're going
to find that they shouldn't have locked
down in the first place so if the CDC
says to close and these individuals are
are suing to open then yeah they should
open
is what I would say thank you uh other
questions thank you representative thank
you representative
wary welcome you were here early
today yes thank you Mr
chair
um for the record my name is Robert
warry I have the privilege of
representing the town of Hudson which is
in District 13 of Hillsboro
County
um just a little bit about my uh career
and background I'm a chemical engineer
who also has a MERS in pharmaceutical
quality from the University of Strath
Clyde in Glascow Scotland as well as a
masters in Regulatory Affairs from
Northeastern University I'm uh familiar
with vaccine development as well as uh
dealing with pandemic vaccine
development um having worked under Dr
Jonas sulk during the 90s when he was
trying to formulate um a vaccine for
HIV um unfortunately his approach was
not successful he was trying to attempt
a similar approach to what he did for
polio but um what I'm here to comment on
is I'm not a co-sponsor but I do support
the principle of the bill in that um
anytime you have a situation where
you're implementing mandates that are
not based in science and sound science
uh there are some extreme
problems and so what I'd like to address
is just a couple of problems that are
noted with the CDC response to the covid
pandemic as well as addressing some of
the so-called signs behind the
lockdowns uh and um bear with me just a
little bit
um I I've basically gathered available
article on evidence uh so there was an
extensive study done by uh Health and
Human Services uh uh Mr McCrae Jim
McCrae uh delivered a report in
September 1st
2022 uh citing a number of deficiencies
and opportunities for improvement within
the
CDC um the director of the
CDC um Rochelle walinsky had a number of
press conferences around deficiencies
with the CDC and
admitted the need to change so i' I'd
like to just for the record and for this
committee's awareness cover some of the
problems that were cited by the CDC and
the Health and Human Services uh
representative so um uh these incl
issues include uh it just takes too long
for CDC to publish its guidance and
signs for decisionmaking they had been
used to more of an academic setting and
really were not geared up to properly
respond to a p pandemic
situation um and their guidance for the
public purposes and public consumption
was often confusing quote confusing and
overwhelming um they also had a high
staff turnover during that time period
um the testing that they first came out
with were faulty with a 33% error
rate
um and as a result the communication
from the CDC uh was summed up as do what
you think is best due to a lack of data
concrete scientific studies to obtain um
proper answers and um just an overall
lack of data so they actually and you
may recall this had a lot of
flip-flopping on device on advice such
as wearing masks testing for covid and
explanations as to how the virus
spread um
there
were uh in in um admitting what was
wrong with the CDC director wilinsky
noted that they need to have
improvements with communication to the
public they needed to change the
incentives from a published published
research approach in scientific journals
to research and data aimed at the public
health policy and proper actions to
address this
um they also needed to have more staff
training to respond to Public Health
emergencies um another problem was the
lab that developed the testing um it was
headed by someone uh who was familiar
with influenza viruses but not the
corona viruses so essentially there are
seven different types of respiratory
viruses Corona viruses one category uh
influenza adov virus uh Rona virus a few
others as well Are all uh different
viruses um respiratory viruses but they
behave differently and modeled
differently um regrettably they had the
the head of the lab for developing the
covid-19 test was an expert in influenza
but not in Corona viruses therefore the
laboratory set up and the protocols that
they followed were faulty to that they
also failed to do um initial quality
control testing using the correct
emergency youth emergency use
authorization
protocol um when they did finally at the
end of a series of testing use the the
correct QC procedure they discovered
that 33% failure rate that I mentioned
earlier despite that finding that
because the test kits were already
repair prepared and ready to go out they
did not do anything about holding off on
the distribution of the test kits having
been in that situation myself
responsible for the release of
pharmaceutical batches and we had a
contaminant or a problem that made the I
literally held back over 50 batches of a
product because of that situation so to
in
my scientific opinion and in my e and
one of the areas of my expertise is in
compliance around Pharmaceuticals and
biological products this
is unbelievable that they would do
something like this it is um unethical
it is improper and
uh basic quality assurance people would
never do this and if they do they ought
to be banned from the
industry so CDC did not stop there they
also failed in different opportunities
to properly study uh different
populations that were exposed to the
Corona
virus they had uh several groups of
people evacuees from the Wuhan
laboratory in Wuhan area as well as uh
300 Americans stranded on a Japanese
cruise ship they could have held those
people in a sort of quarantine detention
they did already but rather than trying
to
ascertain um what behaviors and uh viral
behaviors were occurring with between
those persons who expressed symptoms and
those persons who were asymptomatic or
without
symptoms they um basically uh did not
want to bother the people with the
informed consent process the testing and
the uh additional detention so
a huge opportunity to understand the if
you will the viral incubation rate how
long it takes to uh get into a person
and understand exactly how long it the
symptoms it takes to manifest and then
what the impact would be on spreading to
other people was completely missed so
um and uh if you go into the CDC uh last
word on uh the CDC issues and then I'd
like to transition to discussing about
lockdowns briefly if I may um the CDC
moving forward summary report was
published on September 1st
2022 appendix a contains the uh
recommendations from the Health and
Human Services
findings um and uh that's several pages
so uh they're written at a high level
but they are not in
consequential
um if I may continue briefly on
lockdowns proceed sure all right thank
you um so uh there was some mentioned
earlier about lockdowns I'd like to just
talk about that a little bit is um the
whole concept of quarantining while that
is quite old um the uh quarantining and
social distancing that led to the to the
covid-19 lockdowns was based on a
computer simulation um that originated
with a high school student and
scientists from the Sandia National
Laboratories one of whom was the father
of that high school
student
now the whole concept of
lockdowns was at least for for these
individuals was a computer simulation
where the driving principle was to
minimize the spread of potential virus
by minimizing the contacts and
interactions between
people and so that was a singular
Focus not taking into account any other
considerations um unfortunately and
tragically the computer simulation model
modelers uh failed to consider other
factors and the side effects of
lockdown
um back and this originated back in the
mid 2000s so in the 20062
2007 um time
period um consequently they uh people
who saw this information in this
computer
simulation uh took this two-e Target and
uh extended it into multiple months of
lockdown
which bordered on house rests in some
countries and even some states within
the
US the side effects of the lockdowns
included worker furlows at
256 hospitals adversely affecting the
Health Care System a stoppage of
international travel a 40% job loss
among people earning less than 40,000
per year Devastation of every economic
sector Society wise confusion and
demoralization the discarding of
fundamental rights and Liberties and the
mass conf confiscation of private
property with forc closures of millions
of
businesses I'd like to just also read
some
other
um INE they describe them as
inequalities um in this one particular
article and I apologize I don't have
copies but I can make those available
um
so I this list
is
um extensive well over kind of 50 lines
of of effects but
um uh I I don't want to read them all
but but let me just kind of highlight a
few of them there are estimates at the
side effects of attempting to fully
mitigate the covid pandemic
um you via lockdowns will negatively
impact life expectancy over 10 years the
negative life expectancy from
socioeconomic inequalities alone will be
around the equivalent of six unmitigated
covid-19
pandemics this is not my opinion but the
opinion from this particular article
this is not considering the negative
effects on life expectancy due to
increased mental health problems
suicides and drug abuse the effect of
covid-19 pandemics and lockdowns
differed across socioeconomic groups um
but low those with a lower
socioeconomic
um scale had higher infection incidents
and mortality suggesting that
um the less fortunate groups were
affected Harder by the
lockdowns racial minorities were more at
risk of getting infected than had worst
covid health conditions and outcomes
during the pandemic and the existing
inequalities were
exacerbated um
I I I represent I know you said there
were around
50 anymore maybe you could pick out the
best one the most Salient one and give
give us one more fundamentally so
my I think the greatest impact is to our
school children the loss of learning
from children young children who need to
see the mouth move so infants I think
the socialization among the middle
schoolers
was horrifically affected the
um I can only say this anecdotally but
my my wife is a teacher and I know
counselors within the school system is I
think that there are uh an accelerated
uh much higher rate
of um mental health issues right now
within the schools than ever were before
so
um
so these
are I think the the most horrific there
there are a lot of horrific things that
happened side effects wise I think the
most horrific is the impact that we've
had on our future
Generations thank you representative
would you take questions if there are
any if I can answer them yes I will try
representative gagy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um I actually understood most of what
you said I'm a high school graduate I
don't have all these degrees I taught
martial arts back in the last century
and I learned to break heads rather than
to come to conclusions like you did uh I
wrote down three words here her immunity
delayed all these mandates with the
masks and uh shutting down schools
shutting down churches Etc yes that that
that that that death in in part um
prevent U natural immunity know you
catch it once and you you get over it
right did that um
DeLay So delay getting better um so it
again this would be just my opinion and
I haven't done I don't want to become
like the CDC and make wild conclusions
without proper data um so I I think um
my my opinion is
that the
lockdowns as a temporary thing to
allow Hospital resources and Healthcare
resources to help address it was
well-intentioned
but but fundamentally flawed as a case
example you can look at the country of
Sweden who did not do any mandates
whatsoever but instead
practiced um a much more relaxed
approach
in if you compare the outcomes from
Sweden uh to other European nations or
even the US their death rates are far
from covid are far less and excess death
rates above normal incidents of death um
were far less than other countries and
um you know you could compare that to uh
say Israel which which was almost fully
vaccinated
and they had they had much higher uh
rates um you I think that it's similar
to the US in that uh us has a largely
decentralized health care system based
upon individual states with some
oversight and uh I would say overreach
um from uh organizations like the CDC so
I think in in in trying to answer your
question
um they did not achieve their ultimate
desire if
that's other questions represent
filio uh thank you Mr chair and two
questions if I may the the first would
be a somewhat legal question uh that in
law we talk about the difference between
weight and admissibility meaning that we
determine whether something can actually
be said in court versus the weight that
can be given to a statement meaning
whether we believe it's believable or
not and then how much we actually want
to believe that statement why do we want
to make statements by the CDC and World
Health Organization completely
inadmissible versus just saying we don't
really believe them and allowing each
individual legislator the right to
Simply give it the weight that they
believe it may be deserving and in your
case it may be in other individual's
case may be they get zero weight but
wouldn't this effectively be making that
decision for each legislator that it
gets zero weight and it's completely
inadmissible rather than allowing each
individual legislature to determine the
weight it deserves on their own
merits I'm not a lawyer so I'll only
answer that as a scientist I suppose um
I
think uh to to me the the weight is
always dependent upon the available data
and what you can reasonably draw you
know what conclusions one can reasonably
draw from the evidence and and having uh
full accountability
of or full disclosure of not
only uh successful studies but those
studies that have
failed um I
think what we
found and maybe unlike the
sponsors there are a lot of I think good
things that
CDC um and FDA with the organization
with whom I work most closely uh are do
very well the the problem is when is
when a particular area causes so much
overreach and it's not Based on data so
I I again I I would say there needs to
be transparency of data and
that the information that's available to
legislators needs to be weighed
carefully
um with
without with access to all the data
if I may Mr chair follow up this is
somewhat of a followup one of the
greatest Innovations to both New
Hampshire and American government is
what we call the speech and debate
clause which says that legislators may
say and consider any evidence they wish
on the floor of a legislative body
without repercussion this is very
important because it says that not only
may I consider whatever evidence that I
believe is important but also I cannot
be forced to consider whatever evidence
I believe is important we can imagine a
government in system which I'm either
forced to consider evidence or told I
may not consider evidence which
effectively means that I'm quartered
into a universe of only one piece of
evidence this is important to a
democracy in what way does a bill that
says I may not consider evidence as a
legislator or comport with the speech
and debate clause of both the New
Hampshire and US
constitutions
uh since you mentioned freedom of speech
I think I think one of the principles
that we often talk about is you can't
yell fire in a crowded movie
theater um because if there's no fire
because of the issues that would result
from people having a mass panic
or um and then taking actions to rush
out of the theater that might that would
in fact be more harmful
than uh
not I think in in this case where the
CDC has basically yelled
fire um and then
not specified the parameters of that and
actually
withheld data that would suggest their
proposals and testing were highly
flawed
um
is uh akin to yelling fire in a crowded
movie theater I think it
it's
it's however this bill ends up it's
important that we understand that the
data needs to be available
transparent and
communicated what we have right now is a
pattern where CDC has repeatedly
withheld that
data and not made it available to the
public for decisionmaking
purposes thank thank you for that I I
Know repr M Mill had a hand up
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um you me
mentioned in your testimony that the CDC
testing has a 33% failure rate could you
explain that please yeah so uh basically
there um one of the tests so if you're
making a test you have a number of
parameters that you need
to uh ensure are are viable uh accuracy
precision reproducibility there uh limit
of detection limit of
quantification there are I think a total
of nine or so things that are described
in the United States pharmacopia as well
as other uh
standards what the 33% failure rate came
from exactly I'm not sure but it
probably had to do with um false
positives and false negatives so in
other words you had the virus um and it
didn't register or you didn't have the
virus but it did register positive so um
I would think that that is probably the
33% failure rate is attributable to a
false negative false positive
situation another question uh
followup um is that rate higher or lower
than the average oh my uh yes I mean you
would that's a great question um
FDA us United States pharmacopia and
other areas are expecting minimal
failure rates in the single digits or
less uh you
don't you don't want um those sorts of
tests to be um have a high failure rate
incident I'm not I'm not sure what um it
probably depends upon the the test to be
uh as accurate as I can be um some tests
have greater accuracy than others but
you would not 33% is unduly
large thank you other questions
representative Lloyd so um from my
understanding covid-19 was an unknown um
entity prior to it happening and and uh
breaking out in pandemic um how many of
those other testing
uh kits are
known like so if I have a test for a flu
we know the flu virus we know how it
interacts we know somewhat of of how it
behaves however covid-19 didn't so how
many so if the success rate is being
compared to the success rate of the
other kits how how many of those Kit
rates are
known I I'm I'm not sure I can actually
answer answer your question I will I
will say that at the same time that the
CDC was developing their kit there was
also a kit that had been developed in
Germany that had good testing rates and
um CDC elected not to to utilize that
kit so they instead forged ahead with
their own kit um I would say some of
some of this especially in the biologics
and kind of pandemics and things are not
always um
well known often the flu vaccines are a
forecast So based on what experts think
might come about in the next flu season
and so
they're they're taking um educated
guesses but
um but I would say you know there's a
difference between educated guesses and
guesses
that fail to disclose bad data so I I I
just want to emphasize that is that when
you uh have bad data and you do not
disclose it you're you've crossed that
barrier from educated guesses to
unethical
practices follow up so I guess my
concern here is also the fact that with
a 33%
um unsuccess rate or unsuccessful rate
uh there's a 67% successful rate so um
if if you were the head of an
organization that was trying to just get
anything out there as soon as possible
to potentially save lives uh would you
suggest like trying to move forward with
something uh the CDC itself said that
this was bad that so I I will defer in
this case ironically to the cdc's and
the hhs's review of those practices they
thought it was unacceptable and
um in this particular case I see no
reason to disagree with
them other
questions uh see and rep thank you uh
just to at the beginning you mentioned
uh your background you're a scientist is
that fair to
yeah I'm I'm a chemical engineer I have
a process patent for a
pharmaceutical um I have been working in
Pharmaceuticals biotechnology and
medical devices for approximately 40
years and that's my other job when I'm
not up in
conquered okay thank you and did did you
mention Jonas su's name at the beginning
yes yes I did I worked with him in the
mid 90s um he was um the inventor of
this concept I was in a joint venture
with uh rlan Roar uh and the immune
response Corporation and they had gotten
together and so I worked in that I
worked in a facility I was the head of
quality in a small vaccine producing
facility that uh made HIV uh in cell
culture uh and then inactivated it using
irradiation and chemical inactivation uh
and then um proceed to put in vaccines
for uh human clinical
trials well thank you obviously you have
some um some background in this area
thank you again for your uh extended
testimony okay um our practice here at
the House of Representatives is when we
have these pink cards we give a little
bit of difference to co-sponsors and
fellow legislators and I have five more
uh cards uh from State reps that we're
going to get to uh but before we get to
those and some have asked for two to 5
to 10 minutes before we get to those all
of whom have read have signed in as
supporting the bill and we'll get right
to them but I do want to go to uh
someone who is representing an
opposition to the bill
perspective um and that's uh Carol
Townson and the reason I'd like uh Miss
Townson to speak here briefly and I
believe a handout has been passed around
from The Nurses Association is that
correct yes um we have some of the state
reps we that will'll be speaking more in
in a bit um have nursing backgrounds so
I I wanted to give you a little bit of
time to speak in opposition to the bill
and then some of the folks that will
follow you will be able to uh respond to
your concerns about the bill so that's
why I'd like you to uh speak here and uh
welcome thank you yes so I'm Carol
Townsen and I am a nurse representing
the New Hampshire Nurses Association
today um dear uh chair Michael Moffett
and the members of the state and federal
uh relations of Veteran Affairs
committee um the New Hampshire Nurses
Association representing approximately
1,200 nurses urges you to vote in
expedient to legislate on HB 1156 this
bill would require that all political
subdivisions in New Hampshire not engage
in the enforcement of any requirements
mandates recommendations instructions or
guidance from either CDC or who um the
CDC and the who detect and respond to
new and emerging Health threats and both
play an advisory role in New Hampshire
adoption of 1156 would impede New
Hampshire's access to current
recommendations from leading P public
health experts regarding the prevention
and treatment of communicable disease
adoption of 115 56 would also impede
access to federal funds from the CDC and
from other sources that require
compliance with CDC guidelines nurses
practice from evidence-based research
and they depend upon expertise that the
CDC and the who provide to address
Public Health threats 1156 runs counter
to nurses commitment to protecting the
Public's Health and Welfare I have been
a nurse for over 31 years and you
utilize the expert guidance published by
the CDC in caring for active TB patients
HIV positive patients and many patients
on contact Airborne or droplet
precautions the CDC guidance has kept me
and my patients safe as a member of the
incident command during the co9 pandemic
I relied on scientific guidance from the
CDC to protect patients and staff this
guidance was based on on scientific data
and in my opinion as a subject matter
expert saved many lives please vote
against the passage of this
Bill thank thank you very much we take
questions if there are any other
questions I have one quick question and
that has to do you mentioned um the some
of the information from said the CDC uh
gets to nurses um could you just explain
that process a little bit I know every
hospital every Clinic is a little bit
different but uh did do you get like a
memo from from somebody that cites the
CDC recommendations how does that filter
down if you could speak to that a little
bit absolutely so as incident command I
was actually a nursing director and I
was going to the CDC website and looking
directly at what they were offering at
the time for what's new what's the
information what what Guidance Do we
have for our patients
and we were looking through that and
making the best judgment that we could
with that guidance and it was changing
rapidly we were in a pandemic everyone
was frightened we didn't no one knew how
to handle this situation we'd never been
there before and we also were proceeding
with caution um so we were using that
guidance and making the best decision
possible for our patients and our staff
and we did proceed with caution
sometimes we used their guidance and we
actually went to even more cautious
steps so we use that guidance and we set
mask mandates you know hand
sanitizing hand washing uh all the
isolation um the social distancing all
of that guidance and teaching and
education and we put all of that in
information out for patients for staff
all of
that uh ripson
Rollins thank you Mr chairman um the
first year when Co hit all right all the
nurses were all heroes I mean they
worked Around the Clock they did
diligent job they spent lots of time and
overtime because our hospitals were were
so overwhelmed the second year it came
out that the nurses had to get a vaccine
or they were going to be released from
their job do you feel that that was the
right move I'm used to that I've always
had to get a flu vaccine I've had to
have vaccines my whole life being a
nurse that's what our patients want us
to do to protect them they don't want us
to have diseases that then we spread to
them so that's been my whole life that
I've been vaccinated I'm not I'm not
that's not unfamiliar to me
so it wasn't a surprise thank you
yeah uh one more quick question um was
there ever any push back uh and I know
you just have a piece of the nurse ing
Healthcare World um was there ever to
your knowledge push back on the on the
part of uh healthare professionals
nurses or doctors to some of the CD
guidelines uh that were passed down did
any nurses say uh I don't agree and I'm
not going to do it um so there was a
small percentage of staff that were
against vaccination there was a small
percentage of staff that were against
masking but I was small very small
small than thank
you the
questions thank you so much and thank
you for the written testimony that's
always very helpful to to file
here okay uh I'd like to go to uh back
to our State Rep representative Leah
kushman uh I think we have a couple of
nurses here I know representative
kushman definitely is one of them uh
welcome representative
kushman thank you chairman Moffet I've
never been before this Comm committee
for my record for the record my name is
Leah kushman I represent the town of
wear um I am a registered nurse but I'm
not testifying today as a subject matter
expert as a nurse um I'm repres uh
testifying as myself as a person who
happens to be a nurse I have some
experience with all of that and happy to
answer questions on that but
um I really wanted to address a couple
of issues that were raised um a couple
questions and um the constit ution and
and jurisdiction so um there is a court
case Worcester versus Plymouth it's a
Supreme Court case for New Hampshire um
and in that court case the Supreme Court
made it clear that the constitution is
divided into two parts Part One are our
rights and that they're reserved back to
the people government can't touch them
can't make any laws uh relating to them
or bridging them and that those rights
are kept
unless uh they are determined to be
suspended by a
trial um by a jury of your
peers that being said part two of The
Constitution uh directs the government
how to carry out its duties and
functions to preserve the rights of the
people and there is no Grant in part two
for the jurisdiction that the people
granted to their agents in
government to then uh pass
along their authority to a
non-governmental
entity so if there's some issues with
the last line of the bill um about
citing the
CDC
perhaps that can be adjusted a little
bit um but I think
that it's clear the founders said that
we had to have an informed populace and
informed legislators but you hear all
the the time people just talk about
statutes and kind of ignore the
Constitution and while the CDC and who
already don't have jurisdiction over the
people of New
Hampshire per the Constitution because
it's clear who does have that
jurisdiction in part
two and there's a maxim of law that says
what's been delegated cannot be
delegated
again um I think there is some Merit to
the question of debate so if if you know
during a hearing the CDC or who
recommendations are weighed it's fair
that that's brought up in debate and
kept in the record um so that the
legislative intent of something is
known um but you can't have in law
pursuant to the who
recommendations um a lot of times you'll
see in administrative rules and that's
different because that's directing how
government operates um you'll see
they'll say uh the person must be
licensed according to these um
requirements from the CDC or um actually
some statutes
say uh you know CDC
recommendations you know pursuant to
them this bill would would make it clear
that that's that's not okay um and I
think that's important for the
Constitutional intention of the founders
that the agents who are elected by the
people or appointed by the governor or
uh and the uh executive counsel that
those be the people who make decisions
for them um as their agents and in their
interest um the CDC and the who are
not uh they they're not beholden to the
people uh they they do have expert
information um that is is often errant
and I think it been called into
question much more in the last four
years but even before that there were
some some recommendations that you know
profession other professional
organizations would disagree
with um that being
said uh I I will kind of try to talk
about the nursing aspect a little bit um
my experience was that many many nurses
were upset with the mandates coming down
um and personally I I've looked at
recommendations and and it's
it's it's encouraged in nursing school
for us to be critical thinkers and to
question um directives that come down
from on high and to make sure that the
evidence is robust and it really backs
up those
recommendations um I don't think
that a private company carrying out
their policies and basing it on uh
organizations that they're used to and
um typically provide good guidance on
certain things like basic infection
control measures um for diseases that
have been around for a long time like
TB and I I don't think that that is
comparable to uh talking about the
government being able to site that
organization that's a non-governmental
it as
justification for a law there has to be
a constitutional
justification and that's the only that's
the only way that you can really justify
any law that's
made um but as far as nursing sorry I
got um off track sometimes the
recommendations are are questionable uh
and individual facilities will decide
not to go with CDC recommendations and
we'll go with another Professional
Organization or they'll do literature
review themselves and set their own
policies and as far as it being a small
amount of nurses I I very much disagree
with that as I um I helped a lot of
nurses seeking exemptions
because just because you've had your
rights trampled your constitutional
rights which no one has a right to take
from you um just because you've had them
trampled over and over and you're used
to it you're used to having that abuse
that doesn't make it
okay um and a lot of nurses realized
that during the co mandate the covid
vaccine mandates and they drew a line
and we have an accelerated and
exacerbated Staffing shortage as a
result of it I can name I can give you
the names of 20 nurses who are no longer
practicing nursing because of the way
that everything was hand handled during
Co
additionally
um I am not a member of the organization
that was here speaking before so I just
want to clarify that so I'm not speaking
for them um I believe that some of the
professional organizations are subject
to bias as well and that's why I don't
join um and it's unfortunate that
there's no representation for the number
of nurses who did push back and and and
wanted to fix their profession and what
was
happening and they were not supported
and it's it's unfortunate that that had
to take place because it made it harder
for all nurses when we lost a portion of
some of them and it made it harder for
the
patients thank you representative uh
would you take questions if there are
any are there any
questions thank you so much thank you
representative beler is in the
house
welcome thank you Mr chair honorable
members of the committee for the record
representative Mike beler Carol District
4 this Bill acts to nullify in a soft
manner the World Health Organization and
and the
CDC now let me preface my comments with
this I'm going to make some claims that
will challenge you I will present
evidence for these claims but this
evidence only barely scratches the
surface of what is out there for good
vetted evidence for what I am about to
say under covid it is now known that
early EXT extremely aggressive
ventilator guidelines for significantly
ill patients caused significant
numbers of unnecessary morbility
morbidity and
mortality these guidelines killed
Americans where did these guidelines
come
from they were promulgated by the World
Health
Organization who then ran and still does
Run the World Health
Organization a gentleman by the name of
Tedros Tedros is not and has never been
a health care professional he is a
career
politician before running the World
Health Organization Tedros was a high
ranking member of the Communist Party of
his native Ethiopia an organization that
I believe is still officially recognized
as a terrorist organization by the
United States of America called the
Tigra people's Liberation
Front how did he get this job running
the World Health
Organization he was placed in this role
du the lobbying efforts of the Chinese
Communist party at the United
Nations which is why under Tedros the
World Health Organization does not
recognize the sovereignty of
Taiwan this is the same Chinese
Communist Party responsible for the
creation and the release of the covid
virus from a military laboratory in
Wuhan this is a fact and the official
position now of the United States
federal government and the Senate
report who was responsible for adopting
and promulgating these ventilator rules
in the United
States that was the Centers for Disease
Control early in covid the Chinese
government ran a series of online
disinformation and psychological warfare
operations involving people dropping
dead in the
streets and lockdown procedures that
included the welding of doors shut in
apartment blocks to prevent the spread
of the
disease and other Draconian measures
these social media political Warfare
campaigns were picked up by regular
media and they scared The Living
Daylights out of the West exactly as
they were intended
to China developed the lockdown model
and went to Great Lengths to scare the
world into adopting
it and they had their man in the World
Health Organization make an official
policy and Export these guys guidelines
around the
globe in the US those guidelines were
adopted and pushed by the Centers for
Disease
Control as a part of this absurd
overreach the CDC issued such things as
Nationwide eviction moratoriums that
lasted for
years effectively a seizure of private
property when this rule when this
guideline from the CDC was ruled
unconstitutional by the United States
Supreme Court the CDC simply ignored the
Supreme Court and continued trying to
enforce these
edicts last year a small laboratory in
California licensed only to produce
covid testing equipment and owned by a
Chinese National with deep ties to the
Chinese Communist Party was reported to
local authorities for suspicious
activity on Investigation the locals
discovered that the lab had dozens and
dozens of samples of Highly dangerous
dangerous pathogens on hand thousands of
live lab mice and many human blood
samples thanks to the Congressional
report that was recently released we
even know that there was a refrigerator
labeled Ebola in
Chinese when the locals contacted the
CDC the CDC refused to come investigate
this
laboratory what did they do
instead they ordered the immediate
destruction of all of the samples and
all of the
evidence which made it impossible to
determine the exact nature and extent of
the threat
make no mistake this was a clandestine
biological warfare laboratory run by the
Chinese government on us soil and the
CDC covered it
up these actions collectively are far
more than mere
incompetence the wh and the CDC are and
have been acting as proxies of the
Chinese Communist Party
actively subverting American interests
on behalf of a hostile nation that is
waging unconventional warfare against
the United States for those who are
familiar with sunzu you will recognize
this as Chinese military
Doctrine these organizations represent
an existential threat to our
constituents this bill is an act of
self-defense and if I may end by
answering a question I heard
earlier we as legislators have no
ability to bind legislators or future
legislator this bill has no effect on
legislators or future legislator as is
typical it is simply binding on the
executive thank you and I will take
questions thank you representative for
already answering a
question other questions represent
Massa thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my cron
representative um you said in your
testimony that uh ventilators created a
more higher Mobility mobidity rate
amongst patients could you tell me where
your Source was for that information yes
that that is a fact that is widely
recognized at this point among the
medical community there have been
multiple studies that have demonstrated
this and I believe you can find that
specifically in the Senate
report uh come again what' you say what
report the United States Senate report
on
covid do you have a date for that uh I
don't but I can try to find that for you
thank
you other questions Pur seber yeah I
just have sort of a comment and with all
due respect um I'm originally from
Atlanta home to the CDC no one knew um
and I have I know a lot of people that H
that work there and
they're not big doctors they just do
they work at the CDC but um they're they
happen to have a fire station their own
fire station and so when you were
mentioning um the destruction of you
know the Ebola se you know they have
different sections at the CDC where they
keep certain
viruses and some are kept separate
because the fire station knows to let a
fire burn if something ever happens
because the diseases need to burn versus
being like sprayed with water and become
further Airborne so I just wanted to
reference that if you have a comment I
just that was more of a comment I guess
I'm typically in a hearing we would
somehow phrase that in the form of a
question I should that was poorly worded
would you would you believe or would you
have a comment that was the question
yeah do you have a response sure I
believe I have I find a question in that
but in this particular case with the
laboratory that was discovered in
California the CDC had no direct hand in
what happened they simply ordered the
locals to destroy the evidence um it was
it was part of the Congressional report
that this should not have happened that
the CDC should have investigated and
they should have determined the exact
nature of the threat that this
clandestine laboratory
posed other question representative
Lloyd so in your testimony you had
mentioned the propag Ganda around um
certain lockdowns now um were you
suggesting that uh these claims were
exaggerated in order to exaggerate the
claim that we needed to also lock down
yes broadly so this uh the Chinese uh
government
undertook along with the release whether
it was accidental or otherwise I can't
say but along with the release of covid
they undertook an advanced uh Psych iCal
Warfare operation primarily using social
media videos of people dropping dead in
the streets again welding doors shut and
all the things that happened because
they had promulgated guidelines um for
lockdown that they wanted to convince
the West broadly to adopt because that
is part of their long-term plan to
eclipse the West in uh economic and
military activity um and I can point you
to the gentleman from security studies
group Michael J Waller um for far more
direct information on that
topic represent Judy thank you Mr
chaires uh I am really surprised of your
testimony where is uh if you know where
is uh Ted W where is he right now Ted
Ros I I have no idea where he physically
is at this exact moment he he is still
in the position of the leadership over
the world Health Health Organization
okay all right thank
you other
questions representative krie so in your
testimony uh you essentially testified
that another tool of warfare that was
used was social media so should this
also be included maybe in terms of um
protecting
Americans um thank you for the question
and I I would say no um because there is
only so much that we can and should do
as a government actor in passing
legislation um and to step into that
territory would be for us to decide that
we know better than the people and we
need to make sure that the people have
access to a broad variety of information
so they can make these decisions for
themselves so I don't think that that
would be an appropriate Avenue for this
particular bill so just to follow up if
that's your belief then why would you
want to restrict them from having access
to CDC and wh
data uh uh to clarify are we are we
speaking of people in general or I I
don't believe there's anything in the
bill that restricts the people from
having access to that information this
is purely binding on the executive
branch so those people aren't allowed
access but other people are no they're
certainly allowed access in the private
capacity it but they're not allowed as
Government actors to utilize um wh or
CDC promulgated things to justify their
own actions if they want to take the
same kind of actions they're going to
have to justify it based on good
information themselves that puts it sort
of within our domain to
regulate other question representative
who was first uh repon
filat the the last sentence says
furthermore any requirements mandates
recommendations instructions or guidance
by either organization shall not be used
in the state to justify any max vaccine
medical testing requirements and shall
have no force or effect in New Hampshire
this last sentence does not recom uh
reference enforcement or the executive
but the word justify is in the sentence
which means that it could reference
debate or uh con deliberation by a
legislative body for example if
I for example if I were to say on the
floor of the house the CDC recommends
everybody mask in the face of this
pandemic that would be a justification
and then if for the house were to then
vote Upon A bill which would require
individuals in the state to mask for a
particular period of time that could be
seen as part of the floor debate which
were to justify that mask
mandate and so to what extent does the
final sentence comport with this the
assertion that this doesn't only binds
the
executive so it's it's it's General
knowledge and generally understood um
under our constitution in New Hampshire
our legislature has no capacity to pass
legislation that is binding on
legislators or future legislatures this
would have no such effect our
constitution is very clear very clear
that our debate is so important in our
deliberative sessions that it can form
the basis of no complaint before anybody
but the house itself so that's that's
just it's not it's a non-issue it's a
non- entity
re M MOA thank you again for taking my
question um it seems like the problem is
with the CDC so wouldn't it be more
appropriate to contact the federal
delegation and ask them to put in
legislation regarding the accuracy of
sources and testing used by the CDC uh
thank you but no um it's it's it's my
belief and I believe some of the others
who are who are present that the federal
government has thus far not been
successful in reigning itself in and its
own regulatory mechanisms in fact the
CDC even ignored the Supreme Court
ruling It's Time at this point for the
states to take our own sovereignty that
we have duly under our Constitution and
say no we're not going to use your
edicts that you have demonstrated are
not in good faith to promulgate
guidelines in our own State we have the
we have our own capacity to do so we
have our own professionals we have our
own experts thank
you uh I see a hand up uh representative
Granger uh this is not how we usually do
business but I want to recognize the
prime
sponsor sure uh yes absolutely um thank
you representative beler thank you very
much okay you're talking about Dr
Lindley thank you for flagging that and
um thank you for the written testimony
welcome uh do Dr Lindley you can um tell
us a bit about your background as we get
right into this welcome
thank you Mr chairman thank you um
committee for having me today I'm Dr
Karina Lindley I'm a family physician
from uh Texas I'm also president of
global health project and P president of
uh Texas Osteopathic Medical
Association I'm speaking today on behalf
of myself and I will be uh giving
testimony specifically on the World
Health
Organization um I'll give you a little
bit of a background on the World Health
Organization and why I feel that is
important um to actually support this
bill so the World Health Organization
was founded in 48 as the health arm of
the United Nations and currently has 194
member states initially it was 100%
funded by the member states but in
recent year this funding has changed
today only 20% of the funding comes from
the member states from the assessed
contributions and 80% % comes from the
voluntary contributions some of those
contributions are coming from some of
the member states but others are coming
from the private Public Partnerships
like uh Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation gab Alliance welcome trust
and others these voluntary uh
contributions are typically earmarked
for specific projects or diseases
meaning that who does not really have um
control over that part of the budget in
March of the 21st 25 heads of states and
international agencies called for a new
pandemic treaty that would protect the
world from Future Health crisis
currently the World Health Organization
is simultaneously negotiating two
documents one of them is the pandemic
agreement also known as Accord treaty
ca++ and zero draft it has changed names
over time and the other one is the
amendments to International Health
regulations International Health
regulations were actually adopted Ed in'
69 and then amended in 2005 as a part of
international law so um these drafts the
draft International Health regulation
amendments they would lay down new
powers for the World Health Organization
during Health emergencies and broaden
the context with which uh they can be
used the pandemic treaty on the other
side is intended to support the
bureaucracy finances and governance to
underpin the expanded International
Health regulations
the war Health assembly is going to meet
in May of this year to vote on adoption
of both of these documents once approved
by 2third of the World Health assembly
the pandemic treaty will go to our
Senate to be ratified and it will need
two-thirds of the votes to be
implemented as I mentioned before
International Health regulations have
already been adopted in 69 and then
amended in 2005 they do not need any
kind of special ratification by our
Congress once they are adopted by the
war Health assembly they are going to be
implemented within 12 months unless the
country member State specifically says
we will not
comply so first we're going to discuss
the amendments to the international
Health
regulations the proposed amendments to
the international Health regulations
would give who authority over member
states by changing the boarding so in
the past their recommendations were nonb
in they were recommendations but the
non-binding has been stricken out and
these are going to become binding
recommendations that will now mandate
the member states to follow instead just
consider these
recommendations States will accept the
who as the authority in international
Public Health emergencies and this is in
the article one I gave you all um some
documents to look
over the Amendments expanded the scope
of the do documents from public health
risk to all risk that might affect
public health and those will include
risk to animals ecosystems and
climate specifically the article 18 of
the Amendments will change the
definition of the public health
emergency of international concern to
include not only actual but also
potential concern that the general um
director General would have so to give
everyone an example let's say there is
an outbreak of something in Jungle of
Brazil and the who hears about it they
send their team in and the team says
well we're concerned the country itself
might say this is really not a big
concern this is something that happens
this time of year every time if they
decide that this is of concern they can
declare Public Health Emergency of
international concern by the article 18
and I gave you guys an example of that
in article 18 the who then would have
have the powers to decide to close the
borders to restrict travel require proof
vaccination or other prophylaxis require
vaccination Place suspects under Public
Health observation Implement quarantine
isolation tracing refuse entry of uh
suspects and affected persons and refuse
entry of unaffected persons to um
affected areas Implement exit screening
and restrictions so the World Health
Organization by this article in director
General by declaring this Public Health
Emergency of international concern would
be able to close down that area whether
the country agrees or
not the who will have power to designate
opinions or information as
misinformation or
disinformation and it can require
country state governments to intervene
and stop such expression and
dissemination obviously that will
interfere with US Constitution and it's
Inc incompatible with Universal
Declaration of Human Rights the specific
article is article 44 in the Amendments
of international Health
regulations after declaring an emergency
director General will also have powers
to instruct the governments to provide
the World Health Organization and other
countries with resources funds and
commodities countries will also give
power to the World Health Organization
over patent law and intellectual
property including control of
manufacturing commodities to be relevant
to the potential or actual health
problem that who considers of
Interest so to summarize this draft of
the amendments to International Health
regulation it will expand the definition
of pandemic and health emergencies
including the introduction of potential
for harm rather than actual harm it also
explains the definition of Health
Products that fall under this to include
any commodity or process that may impact
on the response or improve quality of
life it will change the recommendations
of the international Health regulations
from non-binding to mandatory
instructions that the states will have
to undertake and follow and
implement it will solidify the director
General's ability to independently
declare emergencies it will set up an
extensive surveillance process in all
states which who will verify regularly
through a county review mechanism it
will enable wh to share country data
without consent it will give who control
over certain country resources including
requirements for financial conri
contributions and Provisions of
intellectual property and knowhow it
will ensure the national support for
promotion of censorship activities by
who to prevent contrary approaches and
concerns from being freely
disseminated it will change existing
International Health regulation
Provisions affecting individuals from
non-binding to binding including border
closures travel restrictions confinement
medical examination and medication of
individuals so the next uh document that
they are currently negotiating as well
is the pandemic treaty also known as
Accord agreement
ca++ and zero draft they kept changing
the name as the public was responding to
this document so the treaty would set up
Global Supply Network overseen by who it
will set up a governing body under wh
offices a new who Secretariat and
Conference of the parties to oversee the
whole process it will set up infodemic
management at the local Regional
National and international level to
control the information flow and Free
Speech this is under article 18 of the
treaty um in number one it will instruct
the parties to combat false mislead
leing misinformation and
disinformation and anything that's
considered false misleading
misinformation or disinformation will be
something that goes against what wh says
under article three number two states
have in ACC accordance with the charter
of the United Nations and general
principles of international law The
Sovereign right to legislate and
Implement legislation in pursuance of
their health
policies this specific language fails to
address the issue of the W wh assuming
sovereignty for health matters Over
States through the treaty and in the
event of the
pandemic under article four treaty
directs Nation to surveil for and
perform genetic sequences of potential
pandemic pathogens they find and to
safely handle them under article six the
parties will not only surveil for but
will share the pathogens with pandemic
potential and as they they are spe
established in article 12 the pathogens
are identified to infect humans have
high transmissibility and are capable of
widespread in human population are
highly violent making them likely to
cause significant morbidity and
mortality in humans EXC excuse me Dr l a
couple things real quick um I'm looking
for your written testimonies that come
coming this way okay uh that's on us not
you no no problem I wanted to what what
you were referring to and if you could
get me a copy of this and if if we could
ask you to uh kind of take a minute or
two to uh focus on
your remaining key point because we do
have some of folks that that uh have
been waiting so so proceed I'm towards
the end anyway um another thing that is
very important to understand that this
uh pandemic Tre specifically it's um
this one Health agenda
that is actually under Article Five the
one Health agenda doesn't have specific
meaning if you look at the wording of it
it's very difficult to understand what
they mean but one Health agenda claims
that humans animals plants and
ecosystems are all part of one Health
and that everything on the pl planet is
interrelated and affects Health
essentially under the guise of one
Health wh would have control of life on
the planet they will not need to
prioritize human health but but rather
they could choose to balance human
health with animal and plant Health as
well as envir Environmental Health in
the name of climate
change so to conclude why do I speak
very strongly against what wh is
currently doing they are simultaneously
creating these two documents pandemic
treaty and the amendments to
International Health
regulations in the event of future
pandemics and they are telling us that
the one will happen
we're hearing about this disease X it's
going to be 20 times deadlier we have no
idea what it is that's what they're
saying but it's going to be deadlier so
we have to do something for future
generations and our children that's one
of their favorite
phrases if these documents are passed in
May in
Geneva the pandemic treaty would give
them and the amendments to International
Health regulations would give them
powers in the event of another pandemic
to actually close down our country
countries to issue these things and say
you cannot travel you have to use these
tests you have to use these medications
you have to use these vaccinations for
your population we will not have a
discussion that we're having right now
their recommendations now are going to
become obligations and the countries
will have to comply not only will will
have to comply on the medical front
we'll have to share all our data patents
and different Commodities as they see it
so they can change it in very Equitable
way the word Equity is all over the
document in my opinion this does take
our
sovereignty under attack because if we
have a supernational agency and body
tell us what we can and cannot
do and that we have to close our borders
not allow people in and out that is an
attack on the sovereignty of the states
and especially United States of America
and then looking at the whole censorship
Clause if anyone so if I feel that what
they're telling me is not correct that
this person in front of me needs a
specific treatment but that's not the
treatment that they allow and if I say
that publicly they will consider that
misinformation disinformation and then
they they require my state to censor me
and I do believe that that infringes on
my freedom of speech as well thank you
Mr chairman thank you thank you Dr
Lindley uh for the record could you
again just uh tell us uh I know you
travel to get here who who who are you
representing again I'm representing
myself okay and and you traveled here
from I'm I live in Texas and I practice
medicine in Texas okay any other
questions representative filot thank you
for your testimony the the Senate of the
United States would have to ratify both
of these treaties for them to become
operative correct no sir uh the pandemic
agreement or treaty does have to go to
Senate and be ratified by 2/3 of the V
vote the international Health
regulations were already adopted in 69
and then amended in 2005 and they're
part of our international law they do
not have to be ratified I have a chart
at the end of the document that they
will pass to you and it says
specifically we we actually once the
World Health assembly says that they are
okay with all of the Amendments or they
approve certain amendments we will have
12 months to say that we don't accept
that and which Statute in US law says
that I'm not the lawyer so you're going
to have to find a lawyer to give you the
actual statutes the the other point that
I would like to make is are you aware of
the fact that in the zero draft the
first sentences reaffirming the
principle of sovereignty of States
parties and addressing Public Health
matters notably pandemic prevention
preparedness response and Health Systems
recovery and the word sovereignty and
affirming sovereignty appears four times
throughout the document
I'm aware but my
um my opinion is that if you have a
agency who declares a pandemic emergency
of international concern in your area
and tells you that you have to close the
borders that your people cannot leave
that maybe put them in quarantine
isolation that that actually infringes
of the sovereignty of that
country other
questions thank you Dr Dr
um representative Lloyd had a question
rep representative Lloyd you know her
already all right thank you thank you
thank you um and thank you chair um so I
guess with all due respects because I
know you're a medical professional um so
wouldn't the fact that this and I
understand your concern about the
infringement upon free speech I
understand that side of it but also
wouldn't this prevent um situations that
we had gotten into with things like
unapproved treatments having happened um
during the covid pandemic things like
ican being um taken or you know bleach
or any of those types of things thank
you for your question so as a physician
um I treat a person in front of me and
also I am allowed to to use medications
that were not specifically approved for
that intention so long as I discuss with
my patient risk and benefits and uh as
if I follow science and literature and
see that there is a reason for certain
things even Dr fouchi said that during
um that for Corona virus's
hydroxychloroquine is uh well known to
work well he said it before the pandemic
and then um the contention of many of
our physician who have treated our
patients and who did it really well is
that the reason we were not allowed to
actually treat patients was so that
certain things could be put in place
like emergency use authorization of the
vaccines that could be approved another
thing um to consider is when the
pandemic started one thing that never
made sense and it will never make sense
to me is as Physicians we were told tell
your patient to stay home until they can
breathe and then tell them to go to the
hospital so as a physician if in an
event that something happens I would
expect myself and my colleagues to be
the first wants to go in even if we
don't know what it is because it's our
job to save lives so I would say that
the intentions of CDC and the guidelines
from these different organizations were
wrong from the
beginning thank you again Dr Lindley I
know you have a plane to
catch thank and thank you again for the
written testimony that's always as I
said appreciated okay we have seven more
cards most of whom are asking for uh 2
minutes or 3 minutes uh so let's get to
them
and again is in the past uh we're
looking the committee is looking for uh
new new information so any points that
have already been made uh don't feel a
need to reiterate we're looking for for
some new uh perspectives and new
information as we uh as we finish up
here uh representative Burnham is here
um she asked for a minute we can do that
easily representative Burnham thank
you
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members um I'm going to try to skip over
because some of the things are um
replicated already so
um so we can't necessarily change what
happened in the past but we can learn
from that and move forward and one of
the things that I did want to bring up
is at the state's level and how New
Hampshire handled the mandates coming
down from the
CDC every day that's we heard was about
what the CDC recommends and we were
pretty much imposed on those
recommendations no matter where we went
whether it was grocery shopping or to
church or whatever so um however I Look
to what other states did and one in
particular was South Dakota um Governor
Christy gnome did a impeccable job
believing and trusting in her residence
of South Dakota in and and for them to
follow what is the best practices so
um I actually pulled up an
article from July 27th
2021 and it says that Governor chrisye
gome says South Dakota will not have
mask mandate following the cdc's
announcement Tuesday urging urging
vaccinated and unvaccinated people to
wear masks in indoor areas as the Delta
variant of the covid-19 surges Across
the Nation
the shifts the CDC shifts their position
again gome tweeted late Tuesday
afternoon South Dakota's cases remain
low if you're worried about the virus
you're free to get vaccinated wear a
mask or stay at home but we won't be
mandating anything and the cdc's
inconsistency doesn't help the American
people the CDC issued new
guidance that fully vaccinated people
should wear masks indoors and high trans
Mission areas as covid-19 numbers
continue to rise and the CDC has also
advised that children in schools wear
masks this fall information on the Delta
variant from several States and other
countries indicates that in rare
occasions some vaccinated people
infected with Delta variant after
vaccination may be contagious and spread
to virus the virus to others CDC
director Dr relle willinsky said on
Tuesday and gnome's announcement comes
at the heels of the state's decision
Saturday to lift The Mask mandate within
South Dakota prisons for both staff and
those
incarcerated if Joe Biden enacts mask
mandates lockdowns South Dakota governor
Christy noome won't enforce
them it was very bold and and very
um
Fearless I don't think that um our
livefree or die state had that
boldness we did well but we could have
done a lot better and I think that it's
reflective as
to giving that freedom of choice to our
residents and it comes from the state
level I am an elected official at the
municipal level and all I heard was the
recommendations of the CDC we must
follow the recommendations of the CDC it
was like a broken record and I chose not
to and little by little people chose not
to also and some chose to continue to
wear masks as they felt that that was
the best thing for them and that is okay
I just don't feel
that we did the right thing all the time
during that situation that's the first
time we've ever had to deal with it but
moving forward we need to do better for
our residents thank you thank you
representative you take a quick a quick
question sure uh I just was wondering
you quoted Governor gnome what what what
was the date when did she say what the
things that you said she said yes I
believe it was July 27th 2021 and during
the pandemic okay other
questions repres Carrie do you think
part of her success was in fact twofold
one she has a state with a really small
population and two by telling people
they're not mandated to do things they
very often will do what they should do I
can't really speak to what her um I I
believe that she believed in their
freedoms and their choice is what it
really came down to uh and I think that
that's what we need to adhere to in New
Hampshire other questions Ripon Lloyd so
I used to work for the New England organ
bank and often times any uh transplant
um patients have to are are forever
imuno compromised um
how how can uh we as a state justify
saying no you don't have to mask
whatever and we have we have people who
have received organ transplants here in
the state that we need to take care of
and make sure that they like they're not
exposed to
things I just don't think that at the
state level we need to mandate if that
is something under your organization and
that is something that you believe is uh
important to the security and the and
the U well-being of the patients then
certainly I can understand that
follow up were we ever taking people off
of the street and forcing them to mask
yes people were arrested and they called
it trespassing for not following the
mask mandate that was imposed on the
state I actually I am one that actually
lost the job because I would not wear a
mask and I worked at a therapeutic
boarding school which really greatly
affected our youth I can't even imagine
where those children are today as young
adults you take one more followup sure
so but these were organizations that you
were working in or or um entering into
it wasn't just off of the
street well I wouldn't say it's off on
the street but obviously when when it's
being imposed and by the state your
local levels your organizations your um
uh businesses are going to take on those
mandates as law and that's what we saw
we saw people saying it's the law I saw
signs in Lebanon that had signs up on
the sidewalks that said wear your mask
it's the law and it was not a law so I
think it was taken um
indirectly um by the those businesses
organizations schools municipalities as
that was the
law rep representative Sebert yeah I
need to look up the exact date but I
know I even printed it out for a
business near me but um but the the
governor did order a temporary Mass
mandate it was an emergency Mass mandate
yes I think businesses This was later on
into the pandemic probably like maybe a
year after maybe within the first year
I'll look it up it was right after his
election yeah yeah so I was just curious
um you know with that said and what with
what you just stated you know and
businesses also could choose am I right
um you know even before he did that they
could choose to not let people in you
know or clo either close or put up a
sciencing wear a mask in here you know
well there there was um a lot of
businesses and especially when they're
um you know catering or dealing with the
public um they they were required to
wear masks to in order to um conduct
business what was this under the time
that the governor had that in place yes
and it continued even when he he removed
the mask
mandate for specific
businesses thank
you represent gagy thank you Mr chairman
in your opinion
okay the continuing mask mandates in
restaurants and businesses or whatnot u
in your opinion would it be because
perhaps the
businesses because of the sort of
mandate that would be concerned with
lawsuits in my opinion I believe that
many of them were threatened by the um
Health uh organizations that they would
be shut
down
representative seber your hand is up
yeah thank you I kind of a a followup
question to his um so have you looked
into how much um influence I guess you
could say was came down from the you
know to the businesses from their
insurance companies that covered them
per the
liability I am not aware of that okay
thank you anything else
thank you representative uh moving right
along uh representative Emily Phillips
is in the house and is still here thanks
for waiting and um represent mcarter I
know you're here as
well uh represent Philips had mentioned
two minutes uh not a problem welcome
glad you're here thank you for having me
good morning um so I before I started
serving hard I'm sorry I'm
representative Emily Phillips uh Fremont
New Hampshire Rockingham 7 before I
started serving my hard time time here
at the State House I had I uh
volunteered my services at the school
board uh in 2019 I was elected in my
town and then boom this pandemic
happened and let me just tell you from
that perspective um every so the local
control in New Hampshire is awesome
right and when this all broke we were
all kind of deciding our own path if you
will besides the original two weeks to
slow the spread there was an executive
order and then each School District was
allowed to decide how to proceed um so
we you know went remote in my school
district and then um when it came time
to open for uh the next year my school
which um is a prek to8 school and then
we tuition out to high school we were
the only ones in our area to open so
every other school around us was doing
either a um a split schedule where some
kids came on some days other came in
other days or they did a remote um
teaching role until mid October until
everyone got more comfortable and then
they started having kids back so I
commend our school board for Having the
courage to do that figuring out the
space needed according to what we were
following now that brings me to this
this bill is that we chose to follow the
state uh meaning Department of Education
and DHHS um instructions we never went
with the CDC which was fast changing so
we set a precedence we weren't told what
to do but there were districts around us
who were pivoting constantly based on
CDC updates so it was kind of chaotic um
I think DHHS was modeling a lot of their
guidance to based on CDC guidance as
well but that's what we did we kind of
waited for directives from the state
because New Hampshire is big on local
control so I support this bill uh in a
nutshell um On A Private Matter um I had
young children during this period who
were speech and language delayed and it
was very damaging to a lot of young
children to have their peers mask we did
uh face coverings the uh policy that we
adopted so there were children who were
allowed to wear plastic face Shields
especially young children or children
with any any reason really um and some
parents chose plastic face Shields but
my daughter who uh was non-verbal at 5
years old could not see her face uh
sorry her peers faces or the service
providers Her speech and language
teachers were not wearing um face
Shields based on fear right or guidance
that it wasn't as protective so um we
actually homeschooled last year because
we needed a whole mental year of of a
mental health year if you will and now
we're back in a public charter school
because everything is more relaxed now
but jumping to what the CDC says has
damaged an entire generation and I think
a lot of people can agree on that so I
just think that they've made a lot of
mistakes and New Hampshire is very
unique in New Hampshire is not New York
or Manhattan or North Dakota it's like I
I like this local control thing so I
don't I would like this bill to pass
because we should not be following the
CDC based on their past performance and
that local control is essential
here questions R some car I too was a
school board member for 18 years and um
one of the challenges I had and I don't
feel it's reflected in this bill was the
school board in fact did not have
control over the mask mandates in terms
of guidance from the state we were told
if the state masks you mask right so my
thought was if we could just mask you
know when we needed to within our school
district area not when the entire State
or the entire County needed to mask but
we weren't given that flexibility but
that was the state that did
that so we were told um here's the
guidance here's the recommendations each
district uh school board can make their
own decision so we passed a policy that
said face coverings which is the
terminology that was used and a lot of
places didn't they did put cloth face
masks um so I think that that was
partially me pushing that through the
face covering so that we could allow
children or other people to wear clear
plastic face Shields um you know we have
a whole community of children early on
who couldn't wear masks for disability
reasons autism all sorts of sensory
issues which is what I was concerned
about more so than the the the the
freedom relation to it but it's it's
hard for so I I I disagree because we
were because we were very different from
schools around us and like I said we're
in Fremont so we were surrounded by a
lot of bigger schools who had very
different policies very specific so
maybe it's just we took a Gamble and no
one sued us I don't know but um I do
like the local control aspect because
every district is unique versus just
following whatever the CDC or World
Health Organization recommends in these
situations and we were all learning as
we went right it was just
chaos representative seir did you have
you end up okay uh seeing no other hands
thank you uh representative
Phillips okay uh FYI we did have two
other measures this morning one of them
is the prime sponsor asked it be
recessed and rescheduled so it leaves us
with one more measure this morning after
we finish here I want to honor
everyone's time who has uh sat here for
so long uh and get to everyone um
representative uh
M yes uh the clerk already took your
pink card um so we're ready to go it
says up to 10
minutes um so
welcome thank you Mr chair I don't need
10 minutes a lot of what I was going to
say has already been covered so I just
um uh or for the record I'm
representative Nicki mcarter from
Belmont New Hampshire I cover the towns
of Belmont Tilton and samton in bellnap
District 8 my intent today was to cover
um a Supreme Court
uh fight that's going on now Missouri V
Biden I don't know if you've uh had some
really uh downtime and want some real
boring reading but it wasn't boring to
me uh it's about 155 pages long uh
didn't want to print that all out for
each of you having a copy but it's
accessible
online where I have determined The
credibility of the CDC is total trash is
if you read the uh documents in that
court case
um their motives with the White House um
Administration the Surgeon General and
uh the FBI to censor free speech of
Americans on social media and other
platforms because it didn't comport to a
narrative that the World Health
Organization and the CDC were
promulgating that is uh automatically
dis qualifying anything else they say
about anything should be looked at in a
skeptical
sense just because it doesn't fit
their uh narrative so that makes you it
makes you it should force anyone with a
critical mind to question everything
they say just that this one case alone
and they're appealing decisions
throughout the way uh why are they
appealing Court ruling that are finding
them uh yes they've been in violation of
censoring uh American's First Amendment
right to free speech why would
government entities be appealing those
decisions it's because as the TV people
say the walls are closing in it's
getting discovered that they are nothing
more than taxpayer funded marketing
entities for big Pharma that is my
obviously my opinion but I I I think
that's pretty well founded just from
reading this court uh situation online
which you can all find Missouri V Biden
but it's Missouri at all versus Biden at
all um so I was going to go into a lot
of detail about that until I was driving
out of my driveway this morning
and I live next door to a nurse she's 44
years old works for the conquered
hospital
system did everything she was uh
directed to do part of her employment uh
through the conquered hospital system
got all her vaccinations and her
boosters again she is 44 years
old in the last 18 months she has now
three different
cancers that she has been battling and
having surgeries on I saw her this
morning Wheeling her garbage Barrel out
with a walker she's also going blind
she's unable to
drive she's not allowed to file a V's
report because she suspects that this is
a vaccine injury
CDC she believes has some sort of a I
don't know a hold over the
administration in that hospital system
that they're not allowed to even uh
explore whether or not this is vaccine
uh injury related she did what she was
told to do per a CDC
recommended procedure at her Hospital
group she's 44 years old my youngest
stepdaughter she's had her menstrual per
period for going on 2 years now in about
uh 6 weeks it'll be 2 years and that was
after getting a CDC recommended vaccine
at nhti when she was going through the
Radiology program she is 22 years old
and she has had her period since she was
20 her doctors also through the
conquered Hospital group will refuse to
even investigate whether this is a
vaccine related injury and submit any
kind of a record through the Vees
program so uh
I really do think that it's on us as
legislators to make our own medical uh
judgments based on our in-house experts
at DHHS we don't need the CDC giving
advice guidance
recommendations January 10th of this
year uh nhid whatever that organization
is there Dr fouchy works for he was is
being investigated and deposed by
Congress on January 10th and in open
court said that the six foot distancing
just came out of nowhere that wasn't
based on science we just invented it we
closed schools we close
churches we put stupid stickers on the
floor and grocery stores to go this way
don't go this
way The cdc's credibility is trash and
all of these things document that
I'm not a scientist I'm not a lawyer I
just can
read that's all I have
thanks thank you representative
questions CA thank you so much we have
four more
cards asking for two minutes Melissa
white is Melissa
here from Penbrook she I think she's
been here before but she is not here at
this time okay Deborah Johnson Deborah
is here welcome Deborah from Grandam
representing herself in support of the
bill hi there
um first thing I want to say is that I
have never in my life which is pretty
long you can tell by my gray hair been
this concerned about losing our
Republic this this meeting that's coming
up in May with who is complete power
grab and that's after the power grab
that they did during what I consider the
planemic so a lot of things have been
covered here and I'm going to go through
my notes and pick out what I haven't
heard people say uh one thing was was um
you know I I I wanted to respond to that
nurse I raised my hand I realized you
don't what is to the best of my
knowledge this vaccine is still under
emergency use it has not been approved
or licensed by the FDA and she said well
I take a lot of vaccines I want to know
how many nurses have taken an
experimental vac or have been pressured
into taking an experimental vaccine
before it's one thing to take vaccines
that are approved it's a whole other
thing to to pressure people and force
people out of their jobs if they won't
take an experimental vaccine that said
this experimental vaccine is turning out
to be a horrible thing when you when you
it it when the people when the experts
that they silenced including the doctor
that was here which I watched I'm not a
doctor I'm not but I also read and and
I've been following this and I've been I
can't tell you how many hours I've spent
watching hearings and watching
testimonies and reading books and
finding out what's going on here and
this is this has been nothing but a
power grab and it and they intend to
keep it going I'm going to give you and
I will if somebody gives an email
address or something to send this stuff
to I'm going to give you some of the
things that I have been uh watching and
you know testimony and and and and
consuming so that you can consume it too
so that you can see what some of these
experts are saying I don't know if have
you ever heard of Dr mccth um have you
ever heard of of all the other doctors
that have been silenced but do
um I I I can't tell you you know it's
hard to come up here and speak when
you're as angry as I am and and as
afraid as I am for our country so I you
know my voice is like this but um
there's there's a man named Carrie
Mullis I don't know if anybody's ever
heard of him but he invented the PCR
test interestingly he died and he wasn't
that old in
2019 um that those are always
interesting things but you can find
testimony you can find interviews online
with him and I'll be glad to look all
these all this what I'm going to mention
up and send it to all of you he there he
he was interviewed I don't know how many
years ago it was but quite a few years
ago about this PCR test and he's the one
that invented it and he was the one that
said if you if you use a PCR test to
look for a virus you will find it
whether it's there or not because the
PCR test apparently just uh amplifies up
a piece of of something and and apparent
and and and like I said I'm not a
scientist or a doctor but the way he
explains it is there's so much stuff in
the air we have stuff that's that we're
breathing in that are just pieces
they're not really going to make us sick
but they're there and if you keep
amplifying them and amplifying them and
that's why during the PCR testing they
talked about how many revolutions they
did so you need to you need to look into
some of this and he explains it well
I'll send it to you I I you know I'm not
going to take all the time Senator Ron
Johnson I think he had two hearings with
some of the doctors that disagreed with
the CDC these are these are doctors that
are world renowned peer-reviewed all
over the place muli is one of the
biggest he's he's one he's one of he's a
world-renowned doctor and he was
silenced um so I I will send you the
links to the Senator Ron Johnson's uh
like three or four or five hour um
hearings where guess who didn't show up
Dr fouchy or anybody from the CDC or the
FDA none of them showed up no Democrat
showed up no Democrat representative or
anybody showed up for these these
hearings in the
Senate um so I mean this has become such
a political thing that makes it even
scarier MTG Marjorie Taylor green had a
hearing um in in Congress in December
and I'll send you that link where these
doctors came and explained um what they
were doing
um there are people dying from the shot
we've got I we've got people dropping
young people dropping dead on the on the
athletic fields and that is from
myocarditis and from what I'm hearing is
the reason it's young people and
athletes that we're seeing dropped at is
because the heart has been weakened and
when they're out there at at their
highest level of of athleticism that's
when the heart can't take anymore when
it normally would if they hadn't taken
this vaccine and it has to do with Spike
protein
um there
is there I don't know if anybody's here
heard of event 2011 did you ever hear
that event
2011 uh that's on the Center for Disease
controls website and I'll send you that
link to that was a a
tabletop exercise with people from all
over the world these these experts from
all over the
world and they were basically practicing
for covid-19 it happened in October that
that event happened event 2011 was done
in in in uh
um it was done in in October of uh 2019
just before all this but it was they had
all the all the it was like a a a
practice session and they had TV cameras
and they had fake news reporters on all
these TV cameras and they were they did
the whole thing about making sure that
they they uh you know squashed Mis
misinformation and all this stuff it was
all practice I will send you that link
too all I'll need is whatever address
you want this stuff sent to um okay on
on the addresses if you go to new
hampshire. goov and find your way to the
legislature or our uh Christina our uh
researcher um can help you with that
address because you have mentioned that
you do want to send some there's a link
to the whole committee you can use so
much stuff and and if you can uh pick
your your biggest best point uh because
I do want to get to there's a couple
more people are waiting so okay I'm just
going to give you one more sure um
Robert F Kennedy Jr he wrote a book
called the real Anthony fouches anybody
read that that is an incredible book and
that has a lot of background on the
stuff that he had fouchy has been doing
for all these years it's the most
referenced book I have ever read There
is reference to every single thing he
says in there it cannot be disputed and
let me just see if there's anything in
here else
that um
oh the you asked why everybody was doing
what what the federal governments or
what the CDC said Remember the incentive
packages that went out don't forget
about the money that went out if the
schools did not do what the CDC said
they weren't going to get all that extra
money so and and not just the schools
but everybody else that was getting
money so there was those Federal
incentives in there for those kinds of
things and and and the ventilator story
that's that's absolutely true too but
there are other people that want to
speak I will get that address and I will
send you uh a lot of stuff I'm not sure
if you need to divide it up because it's
hours and hours and hours of information
but thank does anybody have any
questions
questions thank you so much for that
strong testimony much appreciated thank
you for your patience I know that we've
run long but uh we want to give
everybody everybody
to and uh Christin will help you with
that address for the for the whole
committee and thank you again thank you
all right we have two more two more here
um uh Matthew roads looking for three
minutes is Matthew here there he
is guess she'll give it to you done how
you all doing today whoops good good oh
good the chair is doing good I can't
speak for the committee but thanks for
asking this well it's a very emotional
issue so it's easy to uh you know for
things to get uh uneasy we're talking
about something that nobody wants to
talk about and that's death and dying
and so but the reaction of a society to
crisis is what defines it so um so I
wanted to bring us back a little bit
more to the point of Michael Granger's
uh nullification Bill uh Michael is not
saying that there will be no no time any
advisement from any organization to uh
make recommendations on how to deal with
crisis as such as this what he simply
saying in this in this bill is to not
allow the World Health Organization or
the CDC to participate in any part of
the public life of New Hampshire and
that's what a nullification is it's a
divorce from these two groups now uh it
came up earlier that the
CDC uh whether or not they had Authority
uh over the states and in fact they do
according to their website they could
actually Commander the local police to
uh enforce the mandates that are
recommended by by them and of course we
know that they maybe there's not a
direct relationship between the CDC and
the World Health Organization but actual
or implied Authority is still just as
strong so so we have that um so in this
situation you know and we look at why
the state would make a decision about uh
protecting the people from a virus or an
unknown pathogen I grew up in the time
as a nursing student uh when AIDS was
still a very uh very unknown plague they
weren't sure about how it was being
transmitted uh wasn't in in 1981 they
found the first death cases um 1983 they
they definitely knew that it was
transmitted by Blood and it wasn't until
1987 when Lady Diana shook hands with an
AIDS patient that they realized that you
couldn't get from touching each other so
in the presence of any crisis uh uh
extreme prejudice arises and so the
state is hopefully going to try to
protect its citizens at least from that
uh that metric or that situation as well
so uh so that's what this does now if if
the St the
state uh was taking advice from an
organization that was incompetent at
least three times they would say yeah
this is not a good organization to work
with let's find somebody else uh so what
I've done is I've brought to
you uh brought it to you a report from
the AIDS Healthcare Foundation which
shows you step by step how incompetent
the World Health Organization was and uh
made some points in my testimony that I
didn't talk about right now about how
incompetent the CDC was um so they were
treating it like it was influenza but it
it wasn't it wasn't influenza it was it
was much worse you know so um there
there were just ways things that they
were doing that were not helpful to
anybody and so the question here is that
does the State of New Hampshire want to
do business with an organization that
failed in their measure cost a taxpayers
a ton of ton of money didn't really come
up with the appropriate measures I mean
at least with AIDS like they came up
with those toilet seat covers you know I
mean that was a good thing but masks are
you know probably not a great uh
recommendation they might stop some
droplets you know but are they
preventative so the question we have to
ask ourselves is what can we do to
prevent people from getting sick and
that's what we're really trying to get
around I mean you you're never going to
stop everybody from making somebody sick
and so and I think that's what they were
wrestling with it so their objectives
weren't clear so that's what this bill
does and I hope that you support it at
least to say these groups are no good
United Nations World Health Organization
CDC they're failures and we're Duty
bound to protect the people of the State
of New Hampshire from incompetency
that's all this bill is is for you to
step up and say hey let's protect the
people in New Hampshire and give them
better options when they can and uh yeah
so hi any questions thank you for that
questions
um Cena thank you for your patience and
speaking of patience uh our final pink
car Gary York is was here early and is
uh hung in there uh from hton um
representing New Hampshire citizens uh
so Gary thank you for being our uh our
final uh test testifier and uh welcome
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee
um what I'd like to present to you is uh
basically a short hopefully short cron
chronology of the events of the past
four years this synoptic form
um and I think uh it does involve very
much entities like the wh and the CDC
but other bedmates the NIH the FDA
wh uh I I think U someone mentioned a
book about Dr fouchi and um I would
agree to read that it's very well
referenced um I consider that what
happened is really a a following a
Playbook uh probably engineered by Dr
foui uh and the first thing to ignite
the whole series of Advance back in
whenever it started I've lost track of
time uh was uh fear the four letter word
the f word the four letters fear and we
all know how powerful truth is we
consider it to me I consider it the the
ultimate
powerful uh entity but uh if you want to
make it hard to people to find the truth
or derail the truth you'll introduce
that fear word and it took a huge toll
especially when it was
uh it was accelerated and propagated by
the
media uh
247 so we have to have fear and then we
have to have a poster boy for the for
the whole Playbook and that was Dr
fouchi the father figure from Brooklyn
accent and so on like that so that was a
start of it and his declaration as a uh
self-anointed Authority
expert uh was that he declared that the
only way out of this pandemic was
through a vaccine the only
way by saying so he was in effect
agreeing that uh if I believe that and I
want to promote that then I'm going to
uh suppress any contrary evidence to
that
declaration and so that was done by
cancelling maligning and even
sanctioning
experts in our country with any kind of
uh anti-narrative uh
information uh names that have been
mentioned Dr Peter McCulla Pierre Corey
uh Merill Nass uh who was sanctioned in
Maine lost her license had to go before
the board for prescribing Iva mechon
even though Iva mechon is recognized now
finally too late sorry uh as a means for
Early Intervention which was never
attempted during the initial uh uh
approach to this
outbreak I'll call it a planemic as well
some people call it a scamdemic there
you
go anyway so so by by inhibiting or or
um preventing this news of alternative
therapies that open the door for the
Emergency use
authorization so that was part of the
Playbook because Normal vaccine
development takes years and there's got
to be safety development but by giving
it a label for emergency use
authorization you've you've Sid stepped
those those requirements that would
normally follow for a many months long
uh p production of a final
vaccine so you're limiting any kind of
clinical trials safety data
Etc so um there was um that was
mentioned that was going to take some
time but suddenly well we may have it
sooner than later and it might be only
months now and it came out pretty fast
um wow I mean makes you think that they
may have thought about this vaccine
already you know maybe they've already
planned for this vaccine
and and by the way vaccine um most of us
were referring to it as the jab but
conveniently the definition of vaccine
was altered by the
CDC we just had a hearing the other day
that addressed the issue of the
definition of vaccine it was altered by
the cdz to
accommodate something that is a gene
therapy product mRNA vaccines how
convenient so if we call it a vaccine
everyone knows that vaccines are good
for you oh this is what we
assume not everybody by the
way uh so that that led to the rapid
development and the deployment of all
these doses to the population including
untested patients like pregnant women
children
Etc didn't seem to matter to the CDC
because now when we talk about the
things like the children's vaccine
schedule this was something that was
recommended for the children's vaccine
scheduled the covid-19 shot with no
scientific basis At All by a subsidiary
uh a subsidiary organization under the
CDC called the um as asep advisory
committee of immunization practices who
voted and tell me if you think this is
suspect 16 to0 members voted to approve
this for children 16 to zero no one had
any thought that
we Common Sense tells you that children
who get covid don't get terribly sick
they don't die why are we recommending
this this is the power that the CDC has
on other states because other states
rely on recommendations of the
CDC wrongly in a case like this and you
think of the vaccine schedule when my
daughter my youngest child were born in
1992 to she had 24 vaccines throughout
her her her childhood today there are
three times that amount of vaccines
given including one that's just been
added this RSV monoclonal antibody which
is a which is actually a monoclonal
antibody is a therapy it's not but
they've changed the definitions to
include that in the vaccine
schedule this is again untested
territory foreign protein injected into
kids at Birth in this
case uh so as the story went on there
was some opposition but there was always
an answer to the opposition phrases were
invented like believe the science
remember Dr fouchi was the science he
declared that the omnipotent Tony FY I
am the
science
terms like misinformation which
basically uh is
a another term for cancellation or
invalidation it's convenient
term uh phrases like pandemic of the
unvaccinated this was even spewed by pus
at one of his Fireside Chats he'd get
real close to them like this is the
pandemic of the
unvaccinated untrue untrue untrue the
highest death rate rates across the
world were in countries that had the
highest vaccination rate so throw that
out the
window safe and
effective uh no and no safe well that's
covered by the ver system which is a
dinosaur of a data Gathering system that
is filled out by patients and or
Physicians or not in the case of
previous testimony of uh Adverse Events
including death which is not on the
website for this like death is a side
effect not
included um effective no no um this did
not stop the spread of covid vaccine in
any manner in fact if people were
vaccinated they felt that they could now
freely mingle with other people and
there you go with spreading the
spreading the
disease um I don't know if I said this
or not but um in the when I mentioned um
the only way out of this is through a
vaccine uh it's not in the middle of a
pandemic you do not vaccinate people in
the middle of a pandemic you're not
going to achieve her immunity
because simply put the the vaccine is or
or the virus in this case or or pathogen
is exposed goes to insults and the virus
as Tiny as it is figures out a way to
mutate to create variance and that's
what happens when you when you vaccinate
within a
pandemic um so
um I was lost my trying of thought safe
and effective is where I left off but
today and this is on the NIH website
another bedmate NH which Dr fouchi
belongs to in a in a
subcategory uh this is what it says on
their
website NIH as of January
2024 no biomedical
intervention other than
vaccines prevents disease after exposure
to SARS
CO2 on a more local level conqur
Hospital you go to their covid-19
website how you can help how can you
help
spread how can you help stop the spread
of
covid-19 question mark
answer get vaccinated and boosted
against covid-19 no
wrong another phrase I was put out there
vaccine hesitancy it's not vaccine
hesitancy this is vaccine resistance
we're not going to take this
vaccine these are just convenient words
to use against
us talk talked about uh lockdowns social
distancing
isolating
masking uh we had an expert here at
testimony whenever it was a couple years
ago
environmental uh uh issues was his uh
area of expertise and he demonstrated
that the masking had no effect on the
spread of vaccinees based on the
particle size Etc so that was pretty
convincing evidence um I I I don't care
if you wear a mask Everyone's entitled
to wear a mask but as a resident of New
Hampshire I have the constitutional
right to not wear a mask this is my body
this is my bodily autonomy that was I
was born with I I have to interrupt
we've had the me we've talked a lot
about masks today so it's and you've had
some wonderful compelling testimony but
to to to wrap this up we don't want to
rewalk previous tried P so to wrap to
wrap this
up let me let me give you some personal
stories in my family uh my son give give
us your best story my best
story
uh
okay could I give you two stories please
you you've respected my paat and I
waited to talk sure sure goad thank
you um the Mandate issue uh my son
worked in New Hampshire for a large uh
Social Service organization that took
money from the federal government and by
doing so he was required to receive the
jab uh he didn't want the job which his
his you know his inherent right but he
lost his job because he wouldn't take
the job this is a this is a young man
who specializes in Family and Child
counseling so you know he he's he he's
back at it but at his own business
slowly trying to make ends
meet uh my niece worked at Mass Mass
General Hospital she uh did not get the
vaccination was against the
vaccination she was uh advised that if
she left left by her supervisor advised
by her supervisor if she left she would
be basically blackballed she had to move
with her husband and her young child to
Montana her home is in Massachusetts and
now she's her family's been separated
from the grandmother of the young
child other other family members in that
same family moved to Utah that's the
disruption that this has
caused so um I guess in summary is uh
people assume that the CDC is this
omnipotent all knowing
uh Wizard of Oz I guess um but in fact
it's just another bureaucracy with
appointed officials not unelected
officials and that includes all these
departments including the who with huge
funding by gazillionaires
uh so I'm I'm I'm I'm just
reme reminding everyone that New
Hampshire citizens live in a state that
where we really put a lot of emphasis on
sovereignty of our bodies and of our of
our people so I encourage you to support
this legislation we need to focus on New
Hampshire not from some uh mandate from
on
high thank you thank you for that very
strong well delivered testimony I want
to point out that this is uh recorded it
is on YouTube it will means it'll be out
there forever but I would encourage you
to uh alert some of the folks that you
know to uh find that and then they can
also listen and uh to what you just
shared very well
questions seeing none thank you for your
patience and for your great testimony
and at this time at uh 11
52 uh we will uh in that hearing uh we
have one more this morning I have one I
have one pink card from the prime
sponsor on 1485 it's House Bill HB 1485
representative Belcher is warmed up he's
already spoken to us today the eloquent
representative Bela
welcome thank you so much Mr chair and
committee this one is going to go much
easier um so this bill would establish a
committee to to study the totality of
circumstances surrounding the covid-19
pandemic okay now at the time this was
entered nothing else was going on but as
of right now the speaker of the house
has appointed a special committee to
investigate the response to the covid-19
pandemic now I believe it's still
important ultimately to broaden this and
look at the whole picture but I do not
want to see a duplication of efforts
that's going to waste time um so what I
would ask you to do is if you would is
please consider um an interim study on
this bill that the current committee can
do its work and issue a report and this
can be examined again in a later time to
expand on that uh report and investigate
any other issues that might come up
thank
you thank you representative beler the
uh researcher just uh shared with me the
legislative history on
1485 and uh there there has been this
type of uh uh issue has come up before
and it's been referred to Health and
Human Services so we're going to look at
the legislative history on this subject
and uh and thank you for your
recommendation um on interim study
ultimately that's something that the
committee will uh decide but it uh the
prime sponsors certainly have uh a great
deal of sway um thank you thank you for
all that questions for uh the sponsor of
1485 Cena thank you repres
Bel and that hearing went a little bit
shorter than the previous one I will uh
end that hearing so at this time it is
uh
11:54 uh we're scheduled for a 1:00 uh
we have some guest speakers coming in uh
maybe just before that
um
do can we get back by 12:45 or do you
want a full
hour say again ranking
member uh so we will be having an exact
session later uh we have one hearing
this afternoon plus two brief guest
speakers we will have a brief caucus
after the hearing and before we go to
exact after the speakers and then the
one hearing then we'll have a brief
caucus then we will exact uh so let's
let's do
uh well I I make decisions uh we'll
start with the guest speakers at 1 pm uh
Jason
rep that's what it's scheduled for and
if everything went very fast that's when
we would start would be 130 uh it depend
it depends upon how quickly the uh the
hearing goes we have one hearing at
one no that that is part of the
exact yeah
that yeah it'll be after
1:30 oh okay thank you yep
okay I already ended the previous
hearing uh I I mentioned but I need to
do this formally uh the prime sponsor
for hr31 urging sport of the dignity
through Prosperity act uh asked if in
because he the prime sponsor wanted
someone to be present at his
presentation he asked if we could uh
come back to this next week and I said
certainly we could do that so I will
open uh 11:31
and I will recess it until 9:15 a week
from today on 9 uh
2924 and so I'll close that and we will
see everyone at
uh
uh 1
12:45 okay uh the clerk room at 12:45 45
minutes for lunch we can do that so we
see everybody at 12:45 and our first
guest speaker 12:45 and and just so
everybody knows the two guest speakers
are on the subject of Veteran suicide
our representative finny is not able to
be
with
two minute two minute warning two
minutes
and
one
minute
okay at this time uh it being 1,300
hours uh we will uh convene the hearing
on
HB 20 uh hr22 before we get to that a
couple quick housekeeping points uh we
have uh eight subs today I think that's
a record and some of them are coming in
we'll welcome them all uh when we start
a exec session uh so we'll do this one
bill and then we'll take a short break
uh the uh the red team will have a short
caucus in the office and then we'll come
back and we will run through the exact
uh schedule there are three amendments
um representative mcarter uh has an
amendment which uh representative uh
Carrie will introduce on hcr9 so that
should she passed those out everybody
should have those um representative
Sebert has an amendment on
hr28 and those have been passed out and
representative philio has an amendment
that's printed out that will go uh I
think he still has that those will be
passed out as well by exec session so
there are three amendments that every
should be at every place uh by the time
we start exact
okay at this time uh the prime sponsor
is already in place didn't even need to
call her up uh representative Balden the
prime sponsor
welcome
hello um for the record I'm Amanda
Balden I'm represent hillsbor District
25 um I promise I do have bills this
year that aren't about the 13th
Amendment but you guys got the good ones
um so I passed out a few hand outs the
13th
Amendment a map that printed a little
weird on the fourth floor and an article
from the Associated Press that also
printed a little weird so if you want to
Google it you can read it
online um so I'm sure by now you're all
familiar with the wording of the 13th
Amendment of the US Constitution neither
slavery nor involuntary servitude except
as a punishment for Crime where of the
party shall have been duly
convicted shall exist within the United
States or any place subject to their
jurisdiction so this resolution and I'm
sure as members of this committee I was
on this committee for three terms um so
as members of this committee I'm sure
you know by now that a house resolution
is a strongly worded letter that goes to
whoever it's intended for and whether
they read it or not whether they do what
we ask or not is beyond our control so
this is more um representative of the
sentiment of New Hampshire and in
particular of the New Hampshire
house um so there is a loophole in the
13th Amendment that allows for
enslavement of humans within the United
States if those humans are
incarcerated this interpretation isn't
just mine in the case of ruffen V
Commonwealth in 1871 not long after the
um 13th amendment was added to our
constitution the Supreme Court declared
that an inmate is a Slave of the state
so due to this loophole almost as soon
as the 13th amendment was ratified
States and municipalities began passing
petty crime laws known as the Black
Codes these laws criminalized actions
that were most likely to be committed by
recently freed slaves such as loitering
and homelessness or
vagrancy some of these laws prohibited
former slaves from holding certain types
of jobs and other laws punished former
slaves for being unemployed
plantations accustomed to slave labor
were suffering a labor shortage as a
result of the 13th Amendment so area
prisons sold prisoner labor to those
plantations on the cheap the prisoners
themselves received no money for their
work as returning to their former slave
life was considered a fair punishment
for the crime of loitering bancy
unemployment
Etc the Black Codes have been expanding
ever since albeit under different
terminology such as the War on Drugs
mandatory minimum sentencing and so
forth in the early 1900s the Black Codes
were used to justify over incarceration
and harassment of Italian Americans
during a period of time in which
Italians were widely hated in the United
States the exception in the 13th
Amendment laid the essential ground
workor for mass
incarceration in fact the prison
population in proportion to the total
population has increased by more than 10
times since the ratification of the 13th
Amendment in other words the prison
population is growing more than 10 times
faster than the population of the
country as an aside from a nonpartisan
perspective um support for this change
to the 13th Amendment isn't partisan in
2018 Kanye West met with uh former
president Donald Trump asking for the
same change that this resolution asks
Congress um to take
up also bipartisan efforts are underway
in Congress to close the loophole so
we're simply encouraging them along what
they're already working on and it should
be noted that New Hampshire has uh was
historically not very economically
dependent upon slave labor and as I
recall New Hampshire's only major
influence on the slave trade was in
importing because you know the New
Hampshire Advantage um they weren't
taxing the import of slaves so if you
wanted to bring slaves into the country
it's good to Loop them through New
Hampshire for a minute um but evidence
of slavery existing within New Hampshire
Peters out in the early
1800s so just as New Hampshire didn't
have any privately held slaves for
decades prior to the Civil War and was
on the right side of history at the time
today we don't use publicly held slave
labor in our prisons with this
resolution we're calling on the federal
government to close the book on slavery
once and for all so New Hampshire can be
on the right side of History again and
if there's any question as to whether
this practice
um occurs in New Hampshire I did include
a map that printed like I said a little
weird but the darker spots on the
map which kind of follow a certain line
you may have learned about in History
Class um are the locations of Prisons
that have
agricultural um programs where the
facility receives money from private
businesses when the
prisoners um um engage in agricultural
work and the lighter spots are where
slave labor is not used
and philosophically or like from a
scholarly perspective the difference
between working in jail versus slavery
is when you work in jail you may be paid
you may be paid a very small amount I
think in New Hampshire it's something
along 75 cents a day but you are
paid um you may be required to work to
the extent of restitution like if you've
done some graffiti you're going to need
to clean that up all of those are not
considered slavery um you may have the
option to participate while you're
incarcerated in cleaning or cooking
that's not slavery slavy
is you're required to work for the
benefit of someone who can punish you if
you don't work you're working and
providing benefit to someone who can
punish you when you refuse to work and
there may be reasonable conditions in
which someone would refuse to work maybe
they're while they're incarcerated a
family member's past and they're trying
to mourn maybe they're sick maybe
they're in pain and if they refuse to
work even given those probably
reasonable circumstances there are
facilities in this country that will
punish prisoners who refuse to work even
with those reasons and the AP article
shows us the full extent
of um
the realities of slave labor where
Americans are enslaved in this country
and how it plays into our economy um it
was a 2-year long investigation by the
AP and they found that um in these
agricultural
departments south of a certain line for
the most part in this country um
prisoners are producing things that end
up at McDonald's that end up at Walmart
that you've probably purchased and eaten
in your home and in your life
um and and I feel like the map just
really
underscores the oral history of the
Contemporary intent of the 13th
Amendment and the exception included in
it um and it more specifically the
article speaks to um in the first let's
see I think it's on the first page but
um yeah they speak to the fact that
there were plantations in the South that
are now
prisons there's this isn't conspiracy
theory this
is we have plantations now they're
prisons and the prisoners are working on
them on on that same land producing the
same Agricultural Product that was
produced in the 1800s there are people
today in America who are incarcerated
for whatever reason who are picking
cotton um and not being compensated for
that labor and a large portion of them
are people of color
so I'm hoping that this committee will
support a strongly worded letter to the
federal government asking them to close
this loophole so that we can as we were
in the 1800s be on the right side of
history on this issue just as we're on
the right side of that
line that you all read about in history
class I'm happy to take any
questions thank you representative Bal
and as you mentioned about the 13th
Amendment yesterday uh in the house
session we spent a lot of time talking
about the 13th Amendment with uh
anniversaries uh which is some great
history my my quick question has to do
with uh something you did touch on uh
the prisoners who make the license
plates that most of us Sho that all of
us shoes um get paid uh I don't know
what it is it's very small as you
mentioned so the fact that they are paid
uh that means they cannot be considered
slave labor that that's is that fair to
say I think that's something that a
judge would have to decide um I if
there's uh any case law on that now I'm
not familiar but I do know that it took
me a minute yesterday I I'll speak to
that in a second but I feel like you're
getting at
something um no no go ahead U you can
speak to that a after the debate
yesterday and that sort of surprise
Amendment attempt on um the cacr that
you all unanimously passed with this
committee um I went home I rewatched the
events of the day on that bill and it
finally occurred to me that that
Amendment wasn't
about prison labor at all that that
apparently at some point in American
history someone who had an unwanted
pregnancy claimed that not being able to
access an abortion was involuntary
servitude a court decision was made that
that is not involuntary servitude and
the person who presented that Amendment
yesterday wanted that case law to follow
our
wording uh into our wording in the state
constitution here um and that but it you
know I had to tried to talk to the
person who put in that Amendment
yesterday and I didn't gain that
clarification till I got home but for
what it's worth all of this is indeed
about prison labor enslavement and uh
you know the state's rights and and that
we have an um responsibility to make
sure that all of our ducks are in a row
should anything ever happen to the union
and um that we're standing by our values
our long held values as a state and as
part of this country um and has nothing
to do with abortion just by The
Bu other questions for the prime
sponsor represent Rollins thank you Mr
chairman you mentioned about some of the
Southern prisons that have plantations
are those prisoners forced to go out
into the fields and works or are they
offered to go out in the work for a
reduced
sentence it's the other way around if
they don't go out and work they'll
they're any kind of like good um time
like any good uh What do they call that
like time served time served it's like
you get out earlier earlier release for
good oh good behavior like that gets
stricken so it's a punishment for not
going working on the plantation is a
component of being in
so in New Hampshire you commit whatever
crime you lose your Liberty you're
incarcerated right you read books maybe
you go back to school you get your GED
you start studying law in these other
facilities you are convicted of maybe
the same type of crime and you work the
fields as part of your incarceration so
your refusal to work the fields is in a
sense considered a refusal to experience
your sentence but
there's but the reason there are only
purely economic and financial motives in
forcing these prisoners to work these
fields um it is
not there is no
evidence whatsoever that forced labor
has any relationship to um restoring the
person or uh rehabilitating them it's
and that's that's what's wild about this
map I didn't make this map it's from the
associate press and it's based on a
study from some other organization and
and the AP just visualized it but when
we talk about the 123 in American
history 13th Amendment Black Codes petty
crime laws suddenly a whole lot of
former slaves are now
incarcerated and then they're converting
the prisons uh the plantations into
prisons and so you can see with the the
darker spots are the areas where the
prisoners are required to work and
punished if they don't as a comp
opponent of their
incarceration um and it's and it lines
up pretty well with the economic needs
of certain areas of the country and
their relationship to agricultural work
thank you uh representative
lungren thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
uh so they're
prisoners they're there to be
punished um as far as slave labor I I
I'm just trying to put myself into a
prison cell and if I had the opportunity
to go out
and pick apples I think I'd be really
happy to get the heck out of the prison
so so the issue I'm having is uh number
one they're there to be
punished and I I I just think this is a
move point I don't think it it it's I I
don't consider it slavery I I consider
what they're doing is uh a
punishment serving behind time and you
have the opportunity to work in the iron
uh Factory at the prison or you have the
opportunity to go outside and do
something so if if you're inside
working the metal shop or something so
would you consider that slavery as
well I don't I hope I came across all
right I do so um
there's a lot to unpack there I just
need a
sec the going back to something I said
earlier I know you stepped out for a
minute so I don't know if this was like
um while you're in the hall but
um the difference from
a um philosophical perspective and I
think in many places a legal perspective
Ive between slavery and working is
choice and so I know that and I think
there's um some lawmakers in the New
Hampshire house uh that are formally
incarcerated and they'll tell you that
people who are incarcerated are
generally anxious to work they want
something to do with their time no one
likes to sit around and be a lump except
me but um
so that's not the issue it's not that
they work the issue is that they are
punished when they decline work and that
is
slavery and more specifically after the
um Victory yesterday on the house floor
with cacr 13 um to move it into to the
Senate to hopefully make progress on
adding that to our constitution I
thought maybe I should write something
maybe an noted or something kind of
celebrating it being black history month
and um and the process decided to go
back and the last time that I was here
on that bill I talked about my ancestry
my slave owning ancestry and I was
looking at a very painfully long speech
it had it been 10 20 minutes in real
time made by my um fifth grade Uncle
James Wood Balden in Congress he was a
congressman for Virginia and he was
saying and this was
1830s that the black population they use
a different word back then that started
with an N um was likely incapable of
functioning if free and they didn't they
also did not consider it
slavery as um you said that you don't
consider it slavery they also did not
consider it slavery they didn't have a
moral problem with it because they
fundamentally believed that black people
were not entirely human and he made
these remarks in a speech in congress
with no shame no no like hear me out
guys or anything no prefacing it he said
it because he expected people in the
room to agree with him and they argued
and believed in that time and in his
speech he argued that if these folks
were not held captive that they wouldn't
be able to live proper lives and that
they were better because of their
enslavement and he was speaking as a
slaveholder in that time um
so there I think there is no denying
when you combine the American history of
the 13th Amendment the ensuing Black
Codes the petty crime laws the over
representation of a certain race of
people in our prison system and when you
combine all of that with this map
knowing that a certain chunk of the
country financially benefits from for
forcing prisoners to work against their
will and punishing them when they don't
that this is slavery and it was the
intent of the loophole in the 13th
Amendment to allow for slavery so long
as these people that were not considered
entirely human and were believed to be
completely dysfunctional and incapable
of living productive lives so long as
they were incarcerated and then they set
the bar for incarceration incredibly low
and that bar was are you hanging out
outside of a store did you spit on the
sidewalk do you have nowhere to live do
you not have a job guess who doesn't
have a a job and has nowhere to live a
recently freed
slave so the the connection I think is
very clear and I do want to acknowledge
the family trait of being
long-winded thank you other
questions seeing none uh representative
Lev your hand is up thank you chair mfet
I should have stayed in 20 like you and
I would have had to work so hard but
thank you um quickly
um was there anybody
from the prison system
authorities come to uh testify today and
a followup to know and do you know what
their position is on this because
obviously um they don't agree with it or
you wouldn't be trying to pass this
bill this is a a house resolution a
house resolution is a strongly worded
letter to whoever the identified
recipient is that's all that it is so
last term when we had a house resolution
in this committee asking Netflix to pull
down a particular TV show proposed by
the illustrious Max Abramson of CBR
um that was passed by this committee and
I presumably Netflix received a letter
asking them to take down that movie and
I don't think that they did um Netflix
didn't come testify I don't know if
anyone did other than the sponsor but um
so similarly with this house resolution
it's a strongly worded letter calling on
Congress to do something and it's
doesn't require anything it doesn't
affect our prison system um it affects
the areas covered by the 13th Amendment
which are identified on this map um that
you have in front of you and you can see
that New Hampshire is not included the
light colored spots are the areas where
I had to mess with the coloring to get
it to print right on a black and white
printer because they were green and
purple in the arttic but the light
colored areas are areas where prisoners
work but they are compensated or they're
not punished when they decline to work
and the dark colored areas are where
enslavement occurs in our facilities and
this is just with regard to agriculture
there may be other products that deserve
their own map um so to be clear I would
imagine that the docc isn't here today
because this doesn't affect them and
that's why they don't have a perspective
it doesn't affect them because they
don't engage in this and it doesn't
affect them because it's a resolution
it's just a letter it doesn't change any
law thank you for that and that's that's
well put the distinction between a
resolution and a HB is significant and
do as we mentioned yesterday at the
house session um is is already weighed
in on on this okay um representative
gagy thank you so to boil it down to its
simplest thing which is the only I
understand simple
things this does not prevent
incarceration what it would prevent is
forced
labor it's a resolution it doesn't
prevent anything it's just a letter but
if DC were to remove the loophole
language in the 13th Amendment which
would be a long process and may be
outside of the length of any of our
lives in this room um it would
prevent enslavement in incarc systems it
would not prevent incarceration in any
capacity
thank you rep representative Balden uh
seeing no other hands uh we'll we will
move on speaking of good behavior uh
representative Manion is asked for one
minute thank you there I knew that the
prime was going to do such a great job
in doing the background and that AP news
article I suggest everybody read it came
out I think earlier this week my
girlfriend actually sent it to me
because she knows that I rant about the
this exclusion in the 13th Amendment a
lot and I'm I'm happy to know that she
listens to me um
so my big from the libertarian
perspective that carv out is basically
an incentive for governments including
the federal to just continue making laws
that can persecute either politically
racially whatever it is and they can uh
Target specific groups and it could be
it could even be political dissidence of
the government for example like Edward
Snowden is uh you know to a lot of us a
hero if that man came back I'm sure he
would be doing hard time hard labor and
the same with Chelsea Manning she was in
prison and she expose war crimes
committed by the United States and this
is just touching like small instances of
political prisoners and that's why I've
always had a problem with this
exclusionary phase because not only has
this been used historically uh for
racial reasons but it's we're moving
into a phase where sometimes I I fear
that it could be used for political
reasons questions for the
co-sponsor seeing none uh we have one
more pink card and that is from ofilia I
believe it's it Barett or Barnett from
um
Barnett thank you for being here and um
welcome so the prime sponsor did a very
good job um explaining the bill and what
it's about so I'm going to try to skim
through this as quick as I
can
okay hello good afternoon thank you
chairman and members of the committee
for taking my my testimony today my name
is ailia brette and I am the healing
Justice program associate for the
American friend service committee and I
am here to urge the committee to vote
all to pass on Bill hr22 the 13th
Amendment to the US Constitution reads
in part quotes neither slavery or
involuntary servitude except as a
punishment of a crime whereof the party
shall have been duly convicted shall
exist within the United States when
people hear end slavery in New Hampshire
or in the United States they say we
don't have slavery we haven't had
slavery since
1865 my partners at abolish slavery
national network did a poll with worth
Rises back in
2021 on the federal level and we
discover that about 80% of the US
population has no idea about the
exception clause in the 13th Amendment
specifically allowing slavery and
involuntary servitude as a punishment of
a crime and people are also unaware of
the missing link that still exists to
this day which is convict Leasing convi
leing was before
1865 which by a lot of historians say
was worse than slavery but it was all
put in full effect after the
ratification of the 13th Amendment in
1865 During the Reconstruction period
they criminalized black lives and
started using Black Codes as Amanda was
suggesting and different mechanism like
loitering to continue to incarcerate
black people and force them to work in
mines railroads and in some instances
forcing them to work in the same
Plantation that they were just slaves at
all of this was all of this was legal
because of the exception clause in the
13th Amendment so effectively took the
power to own individuals from the
individuals themselves and instead of
having your normal slave owners you now
have the state that became the slave
owner and they will lease those
individuals out to various companies and
organizations this allegedly went on
till about
1928 I say allegedly because confict
leasing hasn't ended just like slavery
hasn't ended after a cave in Alabama in
1928 128 people all black children men
women were killed the globe was so upset
what America was doing that they
demanded that all of this has to end so
America decided to end it but my
partners at asnn had a report came out a
couple days ago from the assorted press
that specifically in Louisiana and
Alabama they're literally leasing out
individuals and I say individuals
because I don't like to say in me
or combats because they are still people
so they are leasing out individuals to
private companies where they service
goods are sold on the open market so so
the idea that slavery has not ended has
been so hard for people to grasp or
fathom because for so long it's been
something we all have been taught that
it has ended 159 years ago to the day
but if you take a look at all the people
we have in prisons you see that
statement is far from true we now have a
new phenomenon in the United States
before it was based on labor if you were
locked up and enslaved it was about how
much labor you performed but now we have
this thing called warehousing bodies for
profit and control where prisons are
being built just to be filled it doesn't
matter if you work or not as long as
they have possession of your body they
get an x amount of dollars for that it's
a revenue generator let's take Riker's
Island one of the worst jails in the
country and I know because I've been
there before they are making $56,000 to
incarcerate one person and in New Jersey
for kids under 18 years old they are
making $620,000 a year it's not a cost
at this point it's an incentive that's
why we are still being criminalized
hunted down captured and put in these
cages then to make matters even worse
these these private prons are often sold
on the international open market in the
form of prison stocks and jail bonds
which is a literal and technically a
slave trade so I am just going to leave
it at that here for now cuz I can go on
for hours on this subject but with all
that being said I ask for you chairman
and members of the committee to finish
what Lincoln has started and let's end
slavery and its entirety by urging
Congress to remove the exception from
the 13 Amendment to the United States
thank you thank you ailia I do want to
say that uh between cacr 13 yesterday
and in this resolution today a lot of
history has
learned and is being learned and uh that
uh I think is wonderful
questions see seeing none thank you
again for your testimony for being here
yes no problem that is the last pink
card that I have so at this time I will
uh call an end to the hearing on that
measure that being hr22 now a couple of
things uh housekeeping uh we were going
to have a little presentation at uh
lunchtime at the end of lunchtime we
needed to reschedule that because uh it
was explained that we needed to uh uh
publicize uh that on the calendar so
what we're going going to do with the
folks who are going to speak to us on
veteran suicide uh we have a final
session or not a final session but we
have a a new schedule session on Monday
the 12th to take up one Senate Bill uh
at 1:00 so it they've agreed to come
back and we'll schedule them uh properly
in the calendar so they will be back on
Monday the 12th at 1:00 uh before we do
the one bill and exact that one Senate
bill um so at this time um before we're
going to take about five minutes to
caucus uh the folks in the red team we
like we did last time we'll just go into
the office briefly uh probably about
five minutes uh Madame ranking member
you can um you can huddle here if you
need to huddle or you can go across the
hall uh you have at least five minutes
and I also want to recognize we have
some folks here who are just observing
representative Gard is here uh and when
we come back the first measure we're
going to exact will be uh the uh 1041
the the measure that deal deals with the
uh Liberty USS Liberty incident uh
incident or uh episode attack from 1967
we've already had a hearing on that and
we're not going to reopen the hearing we
can't uh but I do want to acknowledge uh
the folks who've traveled here to and
that's why we're going to exact that
measure first uh representative Gart
when we come back I'll give you uh uh
two minutes if you like just to uh
introduce the uh uh the folks the
Survivor I guess or survivors who are
here so uh two survivors I think so
we'll give you a couple minutes do that
when we come back in uh it'll be at
least 5 minutes so uh we'll see
everybody every body back here in in
about 5
minutes
we're waiting on one or two
folks
okay at this time I will call to order
this uh executive session um for state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
uh I want we have probably have a record
number of subs today I want to welcome
them uh representative kcam uh who just
came in uh uh sitting in for uh
representative Ponte representative
Melvin is uh is here I think uh there
there he is and he is sitting in for
representative Harley representative
Connor welcome uh is here for
representative finny uh representative
Boyd uh Vietnam veteran is here in
veterans committee sitting in for uh
represent Ki corus representative Connie
Lang is here for uh representative
O'Neal uh representative manapot is here
for representative Boris both from
nashor is that correct and um
representative Gallagher I believe from
conquered is here for representative tol
and representative rung is here uh for
uh representative schliff who is I think
at a funeral or something like that
today so we'll get right to it before we
do I want to take a couple minutes in uh
the first measure we're going to do is
uh is HB 1041 we had a hearing on this
we had an exec session on this already
we spent a lot of time uh on some
history from
1967 uh a lot of folks uh from the the
two sessions we've spent on this have
have been able to watch this on YouTube
uh I was 12 years old when this happened
I remember it uh not everybody's that
old uh the rules don't allow us to take
any more testimony we can't we cannot do
that uh this is an executive session but
because I wield the gavel I am going to
uh make a decision and give uh out of
respect to uh uh a Survivor or two who
are here I I will give uh a cup two
minutes to representative Gard who is a
prime sponsor uh so before we start the
exact session representative Gard if uh
if you want to take uh two minutes and
just Rec recognize uh some survivors who
are here to witness our session
today thank you chairman and members of
the
committee I want to extend deep
gratitude to Bill lame
and Tom Mullen who's here with his wife
Mickey they travel from Florida and
Maine
respectively they came to support this
investigation into the attack on their
ship and their Shipmates a number of
years ago but still very personal to
them I was able to have dinner with with
Mr Mullen and his wife last night and
it's it's unfortunate that the na ill
just testified today because I think
it's important to realize that just
because something happened many decades
ago it's not something you deal with
every single day it's very personal for
them and I'm going to do my best to try
to
convey the importance of this to you
today and to just address a couple
different documents that were not fully
understood I believe at the
representative we only have a couple
minutes and I don't want to get into
documents I just wanted to give you a
minute or two to recognize these
Survivors by name and then we need to
begin the exact process okay well I just
wanted to say then that the court of
inquiry was the only United States
government investigation into the attack
this is proven in a 2005 letter to a
congressman and that in 2013 the VFW
passed a resolution for investigation
and in 2017 the American Legion passed a
resolution for an investigation into
this attack so major organizations
support this I support this and I want
to thank the gentleman for making the
trip today and I encourage you to weigh
your decision and to to get this done
this this needs to get done thank you
thank you representative and as I said
earlier uh this process uh has
definitely raised awareness to a lot of
people hundreds of people have watched
the the two sessions the hearing in the
first executive session where we
discussed the 1967 attack uh so if
nothing else whatever uh ultimately
plays out uh please know that a lot of
many people in New Hampshire and Beyond
uh have learned or if they didn't know
they were reminded of what happened in
1967 all that said uh let's get to it
and uh so on HB 1041 uh representative
Manion you have a uh a motion yes I'd
like to motion interim study we have a
second second second from representative
gagy would you speak to your motion uh
representative Manion absolutely so uh
we had a failed OTP motion and there was
like a lot of discussion about like uh
you know consequences of the thing and
how it would look like the Optics of the
bill and all that but I I don't feel
that this uh like we can make
modifications to the problems that they
had with the bill with the study
committee we can look into it we can
address all the concerns and we make
sure we can all come together around
this for these men I feel like they were
betrayed by the federal government by
not having a very good uh investigation
into this like catastrophe and it's just
kind of been forgotten about at the
federal level so we need to do something
about this at the state level in my
opinion thank you thank you represent
Manion uh representative gagy you
seconded it uh do you have any words yes
I
do and I'm going to try not to be
emotional tough I was a sailor too and I
sailed those Waters where you guys were
hit a year before
that I was on the USS NOA
d841
my why I second this this I don't want
this thing to die I want those people
out there who are listening to this
maybe the Congressional Delegation maybe
some of their staffers or their age will
be listening to this and dig into this
and don't let this die because whatever
we do here unless they get involved
nothing will happen now this ship
unarmed an intelligent Gathering ship
where was the escorts why were they sent
there and when they went up to the chain
of command who who ordered it SE secnav
Secretary of Defense or did they go
higher and why were they basically
abandoned and why were they uh they were
prevented from uh what I read from this
testimony to take it out from the
Admiral's uh door and not speak about it
so I want to get to the bottom of this
if if it's at all possible thank you
thank you representative does anyone
else have anything they would like to
add or
uh representative Rollins thank you Mr
chairman I just want you guys both not
to know today and everybody that's
listening that this whole committee has
a lot of compassion for what you guys
went through we're going to try to find
the right path forward to get this to go
through and to see if we can get you
some justice thank you thank
representative anyone
else seeing No Hands uh Madame clerk if
you would run the uh roll call on on the
motion of interim study on HB
okay roll call um representative Rollins
yes representative lungren yes
representative Boyd yes representative
livet
I uh representative Melvin yes
representative gagy yes representative
colum Kum yes okay representative Connor
yes representative Manion yes
representative rung yes representative
Mass Milla yes representative maputi yes
representative carry yes uh
representative Gallagher yes
representative Judy yes representative
Lloyd yes representative Lane yes
representative Sebert yes representative
philio yes that is uh the chair chair
votes yes and that would be
20 so we have 20 to nothing with no
objection we will recommend that for the
consent calendar and the last comment I
will make on this is uh in case anyone
doesn't understand interim study means
that we will continue to work with this
a committee will be uh assigned uh we
don't know who will be on it yet we will
figure that out and the committee will
take this up again and try to look at
the language of the original measure and
see what recommendations they might make
for uh reording approaching it
differently to uh to keep this uh uh
this history uh addressed in the way
that it deserves to be okay uh next up
is uh hr28 that has to do with the maram
past situation I'm looking for a motion
from uh perhaps uh representative Sebert
yes um we have an amendment to um
present we've presented it to you um it
just has the changes um that were
suggested um specifically um about uh at
no cost to the taxpayers of the State of
New
Hampshire so you have a motion and on
the amendment which I believe has been
passed out would that be Amendment uh
0242 yes yes so you have a motion to
amend with that uh
02428 Amendment do I have a
second representative lungren seconds
representative seber's uh amending
motion representative cber would you
like to speak to your Amendment um yeah
just as I said before this is a really
important issue I think when we were all
here if you weren't aware or even if you
were it really enlightened us more to
this particular issue and PAs doesn't
really Choose You by political party of
course who it affects and um you know so
it actually is a real issue that's been
covered they knowingly and negligently
and in a premeditative way um have
caused a lot of long-term damage harm
and death to a lot of people um of the
State of New Hampshire they need to pay
for the remediation costs um and pay
that in full so this is a good message
to
send thank you representative
representative
lren uh yes sir um I second what she
said um but it also affects not only
miramac but the surrounding communities
lonere Bedford probably Hudson um and
this definitely needs to be taken care
of thank you thank you representative uh
anyone else have anything to
add seeing No Hands uh Madame clerk uh
let us run the role on the motion of on
the amending motion the amendment
0242 2 H to hr28 this is on the
amendment okay um representative Rollins
yes representative lungren yes
representative Boyd yes representative
levit yes representative Melvin yes
representative gagy yes representative
kcom yes representative Connor yes
representative Manion yes representative
rung yes representative Mass Milla yes
representative M py yes representative
kry yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Judy we bam we
representative Lloyd yes representative
n Lane yes representative cert yes
representative philio
yes and the
chair uh
yes okay that's 20 to
zero so so the amendment passes 20 to Z
uh now I am looking for a motion on the
amended uh
resolution representative seir again I
motion to ought to pass with the
amendment motion is ought to otpa on
hr28 with Amendment
02 42 h and a second second please again
representative LR with the second uh
anything to add to your uh earlier
comments representa no no represent lren
anything to add to your earlier comments
anyone else on this
measure seeing No Hands uh Madame clerk
uh let's run the roll call on the otpa
motion on
hr28 okay representative Rollins yes
representative
lungren yes representative Boyd yes
lit I
representative Melvin yes representative
gagy yes representative
Co yes representative Connor yes
representative Manion yes representative
rung yes representative Mass Milla yes
representative manuti yes representative
carry yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Judy we find
out uh representative Lloyd yes
representative Lane yes representative
Sebert yes representative Philly yes and
the chair we Madam ah we that's 20 to
nothing okay uh meruku with passes uh 20
to zero uh otpa on hr28 that brings us
to hr24 moving uh right along uh that's
the uh the uh resolution that dealt with
ch ch labor one of our subs actually is
the uh was a prime sponsor uh repr of
Gallagher do you would you like to make
a motion on it um sure I would like to
move a to pass on the um
hr24 okay the motion on hr24 is OTP
ought to pass do we have a
second okay uh thank you uh uh uh
Christina our our protocol officer so to
speak uh I aired in uh offering uh sorry
representative Gallagher the motion
needs to come from a a sitting member so
uh hopefully we're not dead in the water
hope we can find someone else who can
make that uh OTP motion uh no yeah I see
uh representative affiliat is a sitting
member of this uh of this committee and
your motion is move on to pass on
hr24 so the motion is OTP from
representative filio um on uh a hr24
still looking for a second second
represent Miller who is a sitting member
uh and a ranking member motions uh makes
second sub motion uh represent Philo
would you care to speak to your motion
this is an important amendment that has
already started to receive support uh
both throughout the states as well as
over time that would bar a reprehensible
practice from continuing in the United
States thank you representative
represent M Miller I'll second what he
said okay anyone else
seeing no seeing No Hands uh Madam chair
uh we'll again go to the roll call on
hr24 the motion is ought to pass okay
ought to pass representative Rollins yes
representative lungan yes representative
Boyd yes representative levit I
representative Melvin yes representative
Gagney yes representative
colcom to garble it yes c c pretend
there's an H in front of it yes that
works I can I can do
that and representative Connor yes
representative Manion yes representative
rang yes representative Mass Milla yes
representative maputi yes representative
kery yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Judy we might have
representative Lloyd yes representative
Lane yes representative Sebert yes
representative philio yes and the
chair chair votes yes that's 20 to
nothing 20 to nothing and uh that uh
along with the first two measures uh
without objection will also be
recommended for the consent calendar 19
okay uh again moving expeditiously to H
C8 uh that's with regard to the
supporting the Article 5 convention
representative Manion uh you have a a
motion yes I'd like to motion OTP motion
is OTP on
hcr8 uh do we have a second second rep
representative gagy seconds that uh
representative
Manion uh would you care to speak to
your motion yeah so the the Article 5
system is in the constitution is another
way for us to for the states themselves
to propose amendments to the
Constitution uh we know that uh Congress
has until
now proposed every single Amendment we
know to date uh I think it's time for
the states to take back some of that
power ourselves to make sure that we uh
keep the federal government in
check thank you representative repres
gagy uh any any
words I'm I'm trying to find it but no I
do not how I have
anymore well representative gagy is
looking through his paperwork I I do
have a few comments of my own that I'll
I'll offer for uh in represent affilia
you had the hand as well okay uh let me
uh go through my notes and I'll go right
to you um two terms ago this this
committee opposed uh the Article 5
concept almost unanimously it just did
not have any legs at that time it's it
comes up regularly however last term uh
we spent a lot of time on this uh we had
a lot of testimony on this and several
of us uh given the new information the
new testimony the time we been on it
several of us uh decided that we were no
longer uh as concerned with mostly the
run the the biggest thing was the
so-called runaway
convention uh issue and to my
satisfaction and to others as well the
the notion of a possible runaway
convention was uh our our fears were
alleviated and in the bipartisan fashion
uh we this committee last year supported
the the Article 5
concept um so some think that the 1787
1787 constitu Convention was a uh which
created our wondrous Constitution was
that a runaway convention some some make
that case uh did it work out uh I think
so I think it's maybe one of the most
wondrous documents that ever occurred
and that came from that Constitutional
Convention and so at that Constitutional
Convention the founders uh created the
Article 5 provision the founders put
this in our constitution as a as a
viable method to address possible needs
to amend the Constitution uh this is
from the founders it's called Article
Five because it's in the
Constitution several amendments to the
Constitution that came about the
traditional way probably came about uh
due to the energy created by people
looking to do an article 5 movement and
and subsequently uh to preempt an
article 5 movement a amendment that
deserved to be passed became part of the
Constitution and the last thing I want
to say is New Hampshire has had several
constitutional conventions of our own
here in New Hampshire uh we've had at
least five maybe maybe more I think the
last one was in 1970s so the notion of a
constitutional
convention uh as a means to uh review in
and possibly amend the Constitution
happens in the state level it's happened
on our level 1933 it it was it provided
the energy for the repeal of uh
prohibition which was the uh 18th
Amendment so I am uh I am okay with uh
hcr8 and I support the notion of uh an
article 5 convention so that is is me
and representative fard has some things
to say
representative uh really would I ever
admit to this but my uh thinking may
have evolved on this issue and of course
that may mean that perhaps before I was
maybe wrong but that never happened so
I'm just becoming more perfect in my
thinking on this
issue uh my concerns before were perhaps
about those of a runaway convention or
the unknowns on the issue but in the end
this was something that was left To Us
by our Founders because the founders
trusted us to have the wisdom to amend
our constitution as was needed
ultimately we will get the government we
deserve so if we have the possible
runaway convention that's the government
we deserve ultimately we as the people
have to trust us as the people to give
us ourselves our government so if we
don't trust a runaway convention if we
don't trust our delegates we ultimately
need to trust the Democratic process as
we have for the last 250 years we will
get the government we
deserve thank you representative filot
uh representative gallager uh our
tradition is to allow anyone to speak
here including sub so uh what what have
you
got um so the comments so far have
mostly been um just about the idea of an
article 5 um convention in general but
um I'd like to point out um the specific
nature of this one which is uh relative
to elections um and specifically
campaign Finance reform um and I I think
the fact that this is for campaign
Finance reform
specifically um is a pretty important
fact because we have seen
um we we we have seen uh
campaigns CA uh campaign spending get
out of control recently and um I mean
this is something that members of both
parties have agreed on um we had the
granny birthday celebration in the um in
the SE house
cafeteria uh the other week and um yeah
she was she was there campaigning for uh
the main fight fine gold um campaign
Finance reform which unfortunately has
been which was by parison but has
unfortunately been largely overturned by
Supreme Court decisions um and yeah one
of the speakers there um Jim Rubin was a
Republican and then another um the um
Matt Greg was a Democrat so that's yeah
members of both parties supporting
campaign Finance reform so um I think
that shows that this is a topic that
there's widespread agreement on and
therefore is something we should have a
constitutional convention
about thank you representative you
mentioned Jim Rubin former state senator
uh who's been an activist in this area
somebody I respect very much and his his
uh word
I I will admit also have influenced me
anyone else on
this uh rep
representative representative Connie
Lane yes um thank you for letting me ask
a question it follows up with
representative Gallaghers I was trying
to figure out what the exact purpose of
this is because it says it will restore
free and fair
elections then it says as described here
in so is it really because free Fair
elections I'm on the election law
committee so we hear a lot of bills
about free and fair elections and I'm
just trying to make sure that it's only
about is it only about the citizens you
know case or is it about all free and
fair elections everything about free and
fair
elections thank you representative uh
the resolution uh on the page one it
says applying to Congress for a limited
national Convention for the exclusive
purpose of proposing an Amendment to the
United States con Constitution relative
to elections and then the rest of the
verbi is uh amplifies and explains that
uh the there's a need for a specific as
representative Gallagher pointed out uh
you don't just ask for a convention you
need to have specific so in this case
they made the in this measure this
resolution they made the case uh be it
resolved that the people of New
Hampshire speaking through its
legislature pursuant to Article 5 hereby
apply to the United States Congress to
call a convention for the exclusive
purpose of proposing an amendment to the
Constitution that restore free and fair
elections as described here and so
without going through in rereading and
and red debating uh the other the verbi
in this uh the intent I I think to me is
clear that to have this brought up at
the convention the ultimate wording of
improving our election policies would
were this ever to get to a convention
would would be something that would be
rung out at the convention but the
purpose as I understand it is is to have
the election issue uh a specific issue
that would come to an article 5
convention
other comments uh represent Lloyd so
didn't we also hear um some testimony
that said something about uh potential
to have excuse me even though that this
is coming up as very limited bill that
there could be some combination that
happens when an if an article 5
convention was
called yes as I kind of touched on a
little bit in responding to
representative Lane uh the the E exact
wording of anything that's discussed or
voted on at such a convention if it ever
happened would would be the product of
the the work at the convention so uh yes
I agree my understanding is that the the
ultimate wording uh on any issue in this
case an election issue would be
something that would be rung out uh as
part of the discussion process at the
con at the Article 5
convention uh rep represent M py thank
you Mr chair I used to serve on this
committee for two terms way back in my
past life but
uh understanding the con um Article 5
convention and
where are the guard rails to make sure
that it
stays with within the defined con uh
parameters of the convention and that is
one of the fears of runaway if there are
no specific guard rails sure uh and I
know you were in the committee with
regard to guard rails the folks the
permanent so-called permanent members of
the security Council I I mean the
uh the permanent me members of this
committee uh in terms of gu reels we
received uh I want to say tons I don't
know if that's the right word lots and
lots and lots of testimony reassuring us
that uh to use your term guard rails are
in place uh I I won't go back into all
that now it we have uh we received so
much testimony from so many people in so
many ways reassuring us that uh all
manner of guard rails are place to
prevent The Runaway convention which is
why we ended up uh being convinced to
support it uh uh representative philia
and then representative gaging to to
address that question the best answer
that I've heard about the guard rail for
a runaway convention is that ultimately
whatever comes out of the convention
still needs to be ratified by three
quarters of states and if something is
ratified by three quarters of states it
probably deserves to be ratified
anyhow thank you that's an important
point that was in my notes to mention uh
I think a lot of folks don't understand
I think if there's an article 5
convention the convention will make
uh by the by itself would make a new uh
Constitution uh in the reality thank you
for pointing that out is uh any proposed
amendments from such a convention would
still need to be ratified by three
quarters of the States Representative
gagy uh and then representative Manion
yeah
um I'm thinking from all this testimony
that we heard over that long length of
time that what's going to be discussed
at this article 5 convention has already
been decided and anyone who goes Rogue
and tries to change that around gets
pulled am I correct yeah to that we uh
passed out of the Senate there was a um
uh delegate instruction bill that says
basically what you just said that within
the confines of what we sent you down
there to do you can't do the runaway
convention they they're not allowed to
and this committee uh also passed an HB
I believe the the representative from
New Market and a representative from
pelen were part of that so we've
addressed that and passed that HB uh
last year to address that concern uh
other
hands seeing none the motion is uh OTP
on hcr8 with regard to supporting uh the
election piece of an article 5
convention uh Madam chair
yes representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative boy yes representative
lebit I representative Melvin yes
representative gagy yes representative
ccom yes representative Connor yes
representative Manion yes representative
rung yes representative Mass Miller yes
representative
Mani no
no I'm really
torn
no representative Cary no representative
Gallagher yes representative Judy we
Madam representative Lloyd no
representative Lane no representative
Sebert no representative philio
yes okay and the chair chair votes
yes okay
155 vot is 15 to five uh this measure
will not on consent um and now we will
move on to uh
HCR 9 hcr9 is uh I don't want to say
it's the opposite of hcr8 but when we
had the hearing on these two measures
back to back uh we had a a very uh
lengthy hearing on uh both of these and
the same uh the same folks pretty much
the same folks who testified uh for hcr8
at the hearing stayed around and
testified against hcr9 at the uh
subsequent hearing and conversely when
we had the hearings uh the folks who
were opposed hcr8 stuck around and and
and supported hcr9 so they're they're
kind of contrary measures so I'm looking
for uh and I understand there's an
amendment uh that we have that everyone
should have in front of them
representative carry would would you
care to introduce the amendment sure
this um is an amendment to to hcr9 it's
been passed out uh part of the
discussion that was had when hcr9 was
presented was that the language was a
little with so many whereas is a little
um difficult to understand so this has
been
reconfigured to make it a little more
targeted do you have it you don't have
it oh dear okay well I've got a couple
more copies
did okay I got it you got it yes uh
there was a copy of the amendment placed
in front of every uh every microphone so
there should and we have one or two
extras but everyone should have an
amendment uh for their review in front
of them uh might be under some other
Amendment or
paper anybody else need one has
everybody found theirs so we would need
a second to uh the amendment and the
amendment number for the record uh
is
04338 uh amendment to
hcr9 uh offered by representative Kerry
uh do we have a second to the
amending to the amendment
motion I'll
second okay we have a second um to the
amending motion from representative
lungren uh represent lungren would you
um or representative K's already spoken
to her Amendment do you care to speak to
your second
or okay uh I will uh I have a couple
comments on
this um having looked at the amendment
um as is so often the case I think the
amendment improves the uh the original
measure uh when I was a a rookie uh
legislator I was in one of my first exec
SS and there was a sub actually who uh
voted for an amendment and then she
later voted against the amended motion
and I being new I said why did you vote
for the amendment and not the amended
she said well the amendment made the
measure better uh but not good enough
for me to support the second time around
so I learned something that day so what
I'm saying here is I uh not saying how I
would vote on the amended motion I I
would vote for the amendment because I
do think it improves the language of the
mo of the measure uh that's that's me uh
other
thoughts seeing none uh the motion on
the floor from representative Carrie
seconded by representative lungren is to
amend hcr9 with uh Amendment
04338 would you uh when you're ready
Madam chair would you call the role on
the
amendment right again all our subs
here she's writing the subs in we have
uh this might be a record number of Subs
but uh so far we're it's working so far
when you're ready Madam all right so
this is uh for the
Amendments representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Le I I representative Melvin yes
representative gagy
no no
[Music]
no representative
colum yes representative Connor yes
representative Manion yes representative
rung no representative Mesilla no
Representative maputi no representative
kry yes representative Gallagher uh yes
representative Judy no
Madam representative Lloyd yes
representative Lane yes and
representative
Sebert no representative philio yes and
representative mofet
yes
six 14-
six so the amendment passes uh
14-6 so the next motion will
be
um anticipating an otpa motion Madam
Madam
clerk with the um to make a motion on on
otpa a
yes and for the for the record on the
amendment before we start the roll on
the
otpa uh what did you say the count was
on that it was
14-6 okay and the uh the new motion is
otpa from uh did you make that motion
Madam sherff Madam Madam clerk not got
there okay we're still waiting on on a
motion on the paperwork here
um Okay so otpa I to pass for the
amendment correct that's the motion that
we're
awaiting and do I hear a
second okay we have an
nopa motion do we have a second on
that with
no okay representative Lloyd seconds
that
um Madame clerk do you wish to speak to
your
motion the amended bill is much clearer
than the original bill that was
presented which is to resend a
previously sent um
uh application yes previously sent
application back in
um because quite frankly it's it is
unclear whether it is still valid or not
valid representative Lloyd do you have
anything nothing additional to
add okay I have one comment on this or
maybe two uh I do think that the amended
version uh represent Mardo work to uh
improve the language which we uh adopted
so we're voting on an
otpa um my comment uh has to
do
with the the notion of res resending uh
a previous a previous measure a previous
resolution okay this would recent house
concurrent resolution uh that was passed
in
2012 uh I am not an attorney that's
something a lot of people say but the
the there were to me and to many others
it's unclear if you can resend some say
you can and some say you can't uh is a
as a concurrent example uh some of you
might be old enough to remember the uh
proposed Equal Rights Amendment which uh
was proposed uh to the federal con our
Federal Constitution in 1972 and quickly
got 10 20 30 uh uh they needed 38 and it
got to 35 but then uh the more time
passed certain aspects of it were
flagged so several States sought and and
passed resolutions resending their uh
ratification of the ER and that was uh
judged to be uh something you could not
do if a state approved the Equal Rights
Amendment um they could not resend their
approval so this is uh not exactly the
same thing but the the concept that I'm
struggling with with in terms of
recision is or resending is uh I don't
know that it's clear that you
can and that's one thing and then the
second thing for me is I personally I
would not resend it anyway I I I support
the uh resolution that this uh seeks to
resend so those are my thoughts on this
and I will be voting against
otpa other
thoughts representative Gallagher um so
I think it's important to consider this
together with the previous one since
they're both on the topic of Article 5
conventions um so I think the subject
matter matters here since this one's
about um a balanced budget amendment and
the other ones about um campaign Finance
I personally think we should only have
one Article Five uh convention
application open at a time and I think
if we're going to have one it would be
better to have it be about campaign
Finance reform as in the previous one
rather than the um balanced budget
amendment like the previous one
was okay thank you representative other
thoughts represent Manion I prefer the
shotgun approach and try to get as many
things as
possible thank you representative uh a
quick comment from me on that I I can
agree with what you said if you're going
to have a uh a convention and and deploy
all the resources to bring people
together if you can do um a little bit
more business uh that makes some sense
to me other thoughts or
comments uh represent Lloyd so um this
is just a quick thought and comment
about um
the whether we can or not I think will
be decided after we like kind of vote on
this um but the primary sponsor of the
original um Amendment wanted to or the
original resolution wanted to resend
that and I am inclined to fall in line
with what the primary sponsor wanted to
do thank you
representative anything
else seeing No Hands uh Madame clerk the
uh the motion on your motion on the
floor is uh otpa on
hr19 I'm sorry hr9 uh the Article 5
convention when you're ready uh you can
read the the role on
otpa representative Rollins no
Representative lungren no representative
Boyd no Representative levit no
representative Melvin no Representative
gagy no Representative ccom no
representative Connor no representative
Manion no representative r no
representative Mass Miller no rep
Representative maputi no representative
KY yes representative
gallager yes representative Judy no I
doubt representative Lloyd yes
representative Lane yes representative
cber representative filio
No 5 15 five and the chair votes yeah
the chair would have and will vote no
no you already said you were voting
no
confirmation 15 to five right
yes so fails 15 to five correct so now
you have the unamended bill to vote
on uh as you were we amended the bill
and then your motion was to pass the
amended B bill which which failed uh
correct back to the origin so we're back
well we're back to an itl motion we're
looking for an itl motion on uh otpa on
the amended so I'm looking for a motion
for itl on the uh
amended
resolution amended atcr sorry I move
itl rep Manion moves itl on uh the
otpa on the u h our ACR is amended do I
have a second second second is from
representative Gagney uh repr Manion the
Navy he's Navy go
ahead uh do you want to speak to the
your your motion to itl I think we've
covered it I think we're good okay
ripson gagy
same anything else any further
discussion the motion is uh to is uh itl
on the amended
hcr9 uh when you're you're ready Madame
clerk a motion is to uh and I'll I'll be
I'll be uh yes that's me when you're
ready uh see you can't you know don't
prevote like that that gets gets me all
confused I
was ex excuse him
what we have plenty of time we have
plenty of time madam
clerk we want to do this correct I think
I may be able to spell all these names
by the end of the day if I if I can say
representative Manu py you should be
able to say representative Kum see I am
tongue tied and that letter combination
is difficult for me I've never heard you
tongue tied in my
life I truly am yeah no it's not
it's my name
is
okay rc9
itl and representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative Boy Yes representative
levit yes on the it representative
Melvin yes representative gagy yes
representative ccom yes representative
Connor yes representative Manion yes
repres representative rung yes
representative massm yes representative
maputi yes representative KY no
Representative gallager no
representative Judy we Madam
representative Lloyd no representative
Lane no representative Sebert no
representative
philio I this is
a no
okay so and the chair you prevot
remember
uh confirming my yes vote to
itl all right the 14-
six so 14- six uh for itl on the ACR as
amended I just just who um moved that
and who seconded the Manion and gagy man
representative Manion and representative
gagy take him where he has to
go what now we're back does
representative gagy get to do the
committee report too no oh that's why we
second so representative Manny yes we'll
be looking to you for the commit uh and
by the way uh is will there be a u a
Minority
Report um
last call for a Minority Report on hcr9
which passed which is itl 14-6 I I don't
think I can do it but you're not allowed
to so
uh there if someone wants to do a
Minority Report uh okay representative
cber we'll do a Minority Report uh and
we're making a note of that right uh Mr
Vice
chair and uh to back up to hcr8 uh
ranion will do the uh majority report
will there be a Minority Report on
hcr8 yeah and representative Sebert also
uh to keep things simple will and easy
for us to to uh get these reports in
which uh are so important okay so acr8
uh we have the reports we have the uh
numbers same with hcr9 that brings us to
hr19 yeah uh did we vote on the original
Bill unamended we're all
set we're all
set yeah we amended we
amended we did the amendment we did the
to pass is amended which failed and then
we did the we voted on three times so
but we never voted on it we just we just
voted itl on on OTP okay on
okay yeah so we're good we're good we're
good so many papers that brings us to uh
we have two more measures hr19 uh with
regard to the Jones act that is a
measure that I had introduced and I'm
going to make a motion of course uh for
OTP on
hr19 do I have a second
hopefully I'll second that thank you
representative Rollins uh so uh the
motion uh by the chair is OTP on hr19
seconded by the the vice chair I will
speak to my motion uh briefly uh we had
a pretty good hearing on I this I think
we had a number of State refs who came
in uh representative Maguire uh Dan
Maguire representative MGO from mamac
representative Bernardi uh spoke at
length and they they I thought uh
supported my my remarks on why the Jones
act uh we need to shine a light on it
and we need to have people look at uh in
in Washington at the value of repealing
it uh that's the purpose of this house
house resolution is to shine a light and
I think that the testimony uh was was I
thought was very powerful representative
schliff uh asked a good question at the
hearing which I hadn't thought of uh he
had mentioned uh you know food uh you
know the Jones act having a negative
impact on on food to like Puerto Rico
represent Maguire talked about Hawaii
and in uh represent Senator Bernardi
talked about you know pipelines can't we
need fuel natural gas or oil uh can't
get the pipelines apparently uh that we
would like uh through New York or or
Massachusetts or or Vermont to get to
New Hampshire so uh whereas
representative Shirl mentioned food
which I think was was a great comment I
hadn't thought of that my focus was on
other things particularly
fuel uh and we gave the example and I
know the folks there were folks who flew
in from Detroit to uh speak for the
Jones act um the the fuel piece of it I
gave an example in testimony originally
about uh oil fuel from uh Texas
Louisiana not being able to come to New
England because it the the boats that
could have brought it to New England
didn't pass the Jones act uh
requirements of being uh American
constructed vessels now this oil fuel
could go go to Europe which it did and
then there were boats in in Holland in
that one example that could bring them
back to New England so uh this is just
one of many issues many of us have with
the Jones act uh it's over a century old
and and the purpose of this resolution
is to recommend taking a look at it so
that uh the F the fuel example I gave uh
that does not make fuel less expensive
when it has to go from Texas to Europe
before it comes to New England so there
are my thoughts on that those those of
you who are regular committee members
will recollect the uh all the testimony
at the hearing and uh Mr Vice chair do
you want to speak to your second uh
that's okay Mr chair you did an
excellent job and there's nothing I can
add that you didn't say Thank you Mr
Vice chair uh other representative
Manion yeah I I wholly support repealing
in the Jones act it's it's kind of like
crony protectionism for a very like a
niche market uh they they they want to
say that we should keep the Jones act
because it allows us to keep
manufacturing ships and all that but the
manufacturing is already decreasing one
of the funny things that M uh
representative Maguire mentioned is like
we can't even have like a a cruise ship
that travels down the east coast of the
United States hitting ports because of
the Jones act you have to hit a foreign
port to come back to Miami it's
ridiculous thank you representative
other representative Philly up thank you
Mr chair and of course I do respect
those who uh support this provision
however I cannot and as pointed out uh
at the previous hearing Commerce heard
this last year because there is no new
idea Under the Sun and as we heard it as
was pointed out in the hearing we heard
a testimony just related to the uh fuel
industry environmental Pro Provisions
related to it but as you begin to
unravel it everything is related as you
look at the environmental Provisions you
start to look at jobs and as you start
to look at jobs you look at matters
related to National Security calling for
a repeal starts to involve us as a state
in matters that are well beyond State
expertise for example National Security
concerns there's a lot to do with this
act that we can't necessarily opine on
not passing this resolution doesn't stop
any individual from sending a very
firmly worded letter to our delegation
in
Washington but as a matter first of all
of state power we probably don't want to
get involved in something that is this
complex and in fact that was the opinion
that ultimately came back to the
Commerce Committee was that the uh
report that would be required to even
opine on this would be so complex and so
costly for the state we don't want to go
there because it is a complex act beyond
that even if I were to be voting on this
today because magically I end up in
Congress God forbid then I still would
vote for it because I do believe that it
protects American jobs we can find data
on both sides of the fence it does lower
energy cost or at least keep energy J
the same because we can find data on
both sides of the fence sometimes when
you look at an ink blot you begin to see
what it is that you want to
see thank you represent filia let me ask
you um so when you in Commerce and you
heard A Jones act type measure that was
not a resolution that was a a Senate
bill was it not it was a Senate bill
that was looking to do a study committee
related to the energy cost Provisions
related to the to study of the energy
cost effects of the Jones
act thank you representative uh the fact
that it passed the Senate do does that
carry any weight with you
um uh not much of what the Senate does
really carries that much weight with me
however uh because of the the fact that
it was calling for a study committee
related to just the energy Provisions I
mean what was very narrow and that
was telling because ultimately when you
start to hone in that narrowly is The
Telltale to me that something else
broader is going on and as soon as you
go to that broader view suddenly
everything unrattled
sure thank you and I again I would point
out which I kind of think I just did
that the the Senate measure was a bill
on a study committee and this is is to
be clear is is a resolution uh which
does call for Congress to take a look
and rethink the Jones act uh other
comments representative Carrie uh I
would just say as this relates to New
Hampshire 12200 New Hampshire jobs we're
talking about we're talking about
americanmade ships americanmade jobs
we're talking about a teeny tiny Harbor
in Port in Portsmith which could not
accommodate the enormous um cargo ships
that are foreign made so you know kind
of we're we're using our own ports with
our own people right now um and uh we
did have some response um from the
individual when you talked about stuff
having to go from Louisiana to Holland
and then back and he said he was unaware
of that and he would check back on that
and he said a lot of it has to do with
the cargo they're carrying and the size
of the ship and that that size ship
could not fit into Portsmouth Harbor and
where we are now so um to me it goes
back to the whole concept of buy local
shop local I I'd rather protect our New
Hampshire jobs and they're great paying
jobs and I know there are 1,200
individuals in the state that benefit
from this
so thank you
representative other representative
filot i i i Echo those thoughts that
ultimately our job here is as New
Hampshire representatives and we have a
job to protect New Hampshire jobs we did
hear testimony that it may increase
energy costs by less than 1 cent is the
value of protecting about 1,00 New
Hampshire Jobs worth about 1 cent yes
absolutely we it also likely in
increases or uh protects National
Security what is the value of National
Security it's intangible but does it
protect New Hampshire yes and our job is
as New Hampshire state representatives
to uh uh myself and interrupts man s
brought up National Security another
piece of this though has to do with ship
building and our ship building industry
is gone uh South so to speak uh we don't
build ships anymore why don't we build
ships we talked about this at the
hearing uh the Jones act the
protectionism of the Jones act uh
doesn't have competition we talked about
or I talked about why the Auto industry
which does have foreign competition is
relatively thriving they're better
because of competition the Jones act uh
hurts our ship building is to it's also
hurts uh you know the infrastructure
that builds ships whether it's at Bath
Iron Works or pick a shipyard uh our
Navy it it's way more expensive than it
should be to build a naval vessel why
because of the Jones act so the Jones
act I think threatens National Security
and that it makes it expensive and
harder to build Naval vessels that's a
comment to the to the National Security
piece uh represent Manion that one scent
was specifically for gasoline they even
when we asked the individuals that came
here they seem to not understand or they
didn't I don't know if they were
intentionally dodging but the natural
gas question was a big one where most of
our power is coming from National Gas
and that's where that pipeline from
somewhere in the Appalachia up here
would be beneficial that we can't get
through New York and
Massachusetts that's so the one scent
was specifically about gasoline they
couldn't really give us a data on the uh
natural gas which is obviously more
expensive we can't get through a
pipeline well and that that they sent an
email um thank you representative man
representative Carrie go ahead they um
sent an email a response that I guess
our gas comes in a liquefied form and
the size of the ships that would come
here with that it's way larger than what
would fit in our Harbor and we don't
have the facilities to store that
liquefied gas the one thing I would say
is like that could potentially be a
chicken and egg thing like why build the
facilities if they can't get the big
ships in in the first place so like if
the Jones Act is preventing like
infrastructure expansion for something
like that it could be a chicken and egg
thing in my
opinion represent Lloyd so I understand
the concerns around building ships and
and that piece of our national security
and I can get behind you on that um but
my question I I guess my biggest concern
here is the testimony that was emailed
to us at one point about this that um
these ships also Supply our ships that
are at see with our troops um and the
chances of a foreign ship being able to
go and approach our our ships that are
at Sea um are a huge concern to me and I
would support you know looking into the
ship building aspect if it was somehow
separated from the security piece of our
ships that are currently at
Sea sure thank you for that the Marine
Corps actually has a maritime
pre-positioned uh prepositioning
uh plan where they have pre-staged ships
and supplies around the world and uh our
own Naval vessels which are built in in
America do c already uh you know we
don't Farm out or delegate out much in
the way of uh moving military uh
transport uh to uh civilian carriers so
uh to your point uh anything that's
ammunition or or important supplies
would uh inherently be delivered by the
Navy uh there may be some situations
where where nonmilitary typee of uh
supplies that would go to Diego Garcia
for example might need to uh Jones Z
might uh impact that I but I I think
it's it's fairly minimal uh so to to
your point which which is a reasonable
Point uh my response would be that uh
our existing Navy would get the this
ammunition and the secret stuff where it
needs to go um and I don't think it
would the Jones act would would have
much impact on um you know doing
anything different from
that um
other other
hands uh R Gallagher her um just a
question can someone remind me what the
current motion on the table is again to
pass motion is O ought to pass on
hr1 which which is to um repeal
recommend repealing the Jones act 19 I
what did I say you say 11 19 hr19 which
is above yes
hr19 OTP motion other
comments seeing no more hands uh Madam
clerk uh when you're ready the motion is
OTP on uh
hr19 okay representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative Boyd yes representative
levit I representative Melvin yes
representative Gagney yes representative
colum yes representative Connor yes
representative Manion yes representative
rung no representative Mass
Milla I've heard so many great Arguments
for and against that I'm not sure where
I'm at um can I tell
you I have a volunteer
um I
think the argument about um New
Hampshire jobs is a good one so I'm
going to vote no okay Representative
manipu no representative KY no
representative
Gallagher uh no representative Judy no
Madam representative Lloyd no
representative nan no representative
Sebert no Representative philio
no and the the chair chair votes
yes
yep so the C the the count is 10 to 10
10 to 10 uh I will do the uh
recommendation for OTP who would like to
do the contrary I represent
filio okay
so chairman have gu
oh
okay okay okay thank you
uh thank you uh to our researcher um so
protocol requires before we uh move on
with the 10 to 10 we we have to also
have a the motion was OTP which did not
pass we need an itl motion uh which I I
think I know was going to come out but
we need to um have somebody make a
motion to itl represent filot has a
motion to itl and do we have a second uh
move itl on hr19 not seeing any second
well do we have a second uh uh repres M
millisecond at okay so the motion is uh
Madam clerk when you're ready the motion
is to itl on U
hr19 so many pieces of
paper take deep cleansing breaths for a
moment while I write in eight
names where's the party where's the
party we were
from uh represent
R thank you um I just want to say it as
as a substitute though I I will be
voting for The itl because I think our
number one priority should be to the
people of New Hampshire and to these
jobs which are wellp paying I just
wanted to go on the record with that
thank
you thank
you any other
comments I'm almost
there
uh R of Gallagher uh so just a
procedural question so um I mean I know
we're on itl now but I'm wondering if
there might be room for of um for if
like we could have done interim study
instead uh that would have been an
option um of course anybody can make
that motion we have a motion on the
floor now of itl that we're about to
vote
on we
ready okay representative Rollins
no Representative lungren no
representative Boyd no representative
levit nope representative Melvin
Representative gagy no representative K
C oh my God
C no okay representative Connor no
representive Manion no representive rung
yes representive Mass Milla yes
representative maputi yes representative
car yes represent of
Gallagher uh yes representative Judy we
Madam represent representive Lloyd yes
representative Lane yes representative
Sebert yes representative philio yes
well Groundhog Day yes it is Groundhog
Day uh chair votes uh uh against itl no
okay all right 10 to 10 10 to 10 and I
will still do the uh one report and
representative filot will do the other
report so uh there we go all right we
have one more uh one more measure uh and
that's hcr1 hcr1 is a resolution a house
concurrent resolution hcr1 uh condemning
medically unnecessary restrictions on
medication abortion so we're looking for
a motion I did like to make a motion of
ought to pass representative Sebert
moves OTP ought to pass on acr11 and do
we have a second I'll second it
representative milliseconds uh
representative Sebert uh would you care
to speak to your motion yeah um just
real quick I just uh think this is
really important um especially because
it sends a message to Providers across
the state that they that they matter
that their word matters and their
opinion matters when it comes to what we
are
legislating and um I think that's who we
need to listen to um if Mass Miller has
anything I concur I think the Prov
providers need to have a say as well
thank
you okay I have a couple comments uh and
then uh anyone else of course will spend
as much time as uh as we as anyone wants
to speak to it all I want to say as I
look at this resolution um uh I honestly
I am I'm sympathetic to uh certain types
of uh medicines the uh notion of an
ectopic pregnancy which uh uh all agree
needs would need to be um terminated uh
you know even the the church the
pro-life people they don't even consider
that to be an abortion to terminate an
un
un unviable ectopic pregnancy so uh to
have uh medicine available for that I'm
very sympathetic to uh if that was the
narrower Focus I think that um that's
something I could certainly try to
support if that was the sole Focus uh uh
this is something that's very difficult
for me or folks like myself to uh
support uh if you look at the We ases
There are are many we asses that uh uh
some
are hard to for folks on one side to um
to endorse um so for that reason and
there are so many pieces to this and I
don't know that we need to get into uh
we can if anybody wants to uh all the
different Arguments for against um uh
abortion RIT large the the the
major issues with with so many offshoots
to that so because of all the whereases
because it is so much there that pieces
of it some of us cannot support I I
cannot vote for for this uh ACR or a
yeah acr1 other comments representative
Lloyd um I just wanted to speak to the
way that the um the resolution was
written I believe that the wording is in
here because our providers are needing
it to be as written um in order to have
things um processed through correctly
and um be heard
correctly so thank you representative
other comments representative
levit I need to make everybody on the
committee aware that this is an ongoing
litigation in the Supreme court and that
any action by this committee would may
end up to be of no value to be
mute thank you representative other
thoughts comments representative Philly
up uh without going to the discussion
about uh the points about abortion since
much of what has been said has been said
before will be said again uh in probably
will be said again when this goes to the
floor this is a case that's before The
Supreme Court which is the value of the
HCR first of course as an HDR this
doesn't bind the body to anything it's
an expression of where we stand on this
issue the case that is before The
Supreme Court should horrify any
rational individual it seeks to upend 20
years of established administrative law
by undoing administrative fact finding
by the
FDA this has never happened before where
the a federal district court has gone
back and undone agency fact finding 20
years after the fact were the Supreme
Court to uphold this this would undo
what we know of administrative law in
the United States let's set aside the
Live Wire issue here were this to happen
what we think we know is the law in the
United States what we think is settled
law is undone we don't know what the
landscape of this country looks like we
don't know what the legal landscape of
this country looks like if this case
goes through and that should horrify
rational thinking people because judges
can go back and undo agency fact finding
and most of the law in this country is
is done by those agencies those
three-letter organizations so regardless
of where you stand on this issue and I
would hope that you support individuals
right to choose but of course we're not
going to go there but I would hope that
you would at least support this case
because what the law looks like if this
case were to not go that way in the
Supreme Court is
Unthinkable thank you
representative uh representative uh
Gallagher and then representative
levit uh so qu question for
representative f um if I may um so when
you talk about um undoing administrative
loss does that mean that this case the
case in question here is the one that
could potentially overturn the Chevron
Doctrine
then or is that a different one yeah
that's a different one this one would
say ask whether or not an agency finding
a fact could be undone by by a court TP
what has happened to this point is that
a when an agency does fact finding we
tend to We Trust the agency to do the
fact finding because they're the experts
in what they do whatever it is whatever
field it is the FDA we trust that the
FDA knows what they're doing in
Pharmaceuticals and that a judge who is
sitting on a bench doesn't know as much
about pharmaceuticals as do the people
who deal with Pharmaceuticals every day
if this happens then what we are saying
is that a judge sitting on a bench now
can overturn turn the findings of fact
of the people who deal with those facts
on a daily basis whether or not you like
that what we deal with a settled fact
every day in our world the law we deal
with every day in our world is based on
the fact that we trust the people and
the agencies who know the facts to keep
those facts it would be a Brave New
World that we would head into if judges
can UND do those agency fact findings
what we have here is the an agency the
FDA 20 years ago found this drug was
safe and effective now suddenly one
judge and District hordon uh Texas said
this was not safe and effective based on
whatever evidence was presented that's
that's dangerous because this is a safe
and effective drug and how do we know
that well it's been used for 20 years
and the large large majority of the
evidence that's out there virtually 100%
of the evidence that's out there based
on now clinical use in the real world
says it's safe and effective St
represent repres LE you had your hand
up well if you want to talk about
facts fact is that this is exactly why
these issues get adjudicated in a court
of
law court of law not here at the New
Hampshire State fed and veterans
committee other hands other comments uh
represent Lane um yes thank you for
letting me speak um I would be remiss as
someone who has been fighting for
medical abortions since I was about 18
years old so I would just like to say
that this is in line with what I have
come to learn in New Hampshire since
1986 that we bipartisan support the
right to a woman's choice and that um
these are medical abortions that fall
within the timeline the 24-week timeline
and if we don't have them it will
severely restrict and it's being done
done in a way that is um I think as our
representative mentioned in a way that
um is goes back to 20 years to ban a
drug that has been found safe and has
never really had any issues with it in
those 20 years and also is available for
other things thank you thank you
represent Lane I suspect that when we do
whoever does the committee reports uh I
suspect that these reports will be a
little bit longer than uh some of the
other ones that we've exec today and
that's important and that's good uh
because this obviously will go to the
floor and uh so I think that whoever
does the reports uh I I trust will will
fully uh make the case um for the the
the two different perspectives on this
other comments uh representative
Lloyd yeah I just wanted to make a a a
note um considering your um what you had
mentioned uh or what representative Lev
had mentioned um this is a resolution it
is a as we heard earlier a strongly
worded letter it does not have any
bearing on the current court case other
than to tell them what New Hampshire's
position is and if we look back at the
testimony that we had heard in the 90s
in New Hampshire New Hampshire was the
first state and Republicans co-sponsored
this to allow Mya prone and uh medical
and to look uh to look through
um uh the the the applications of this
drug so I don't think that we're
necessarily um doing anything incorrect
by supporting um showing our side it
would basically be like us submitting
testimony to a bill that was being heard
um by showing our support to what's
going on um and our side of it in the
courts thank you representative
represent man py you have a hand up
thank you Mr chair I just want to put my
two cents 20 years of medically advised
medication that was effective safe and
for women in the state and all of a
sudden that has not somehow has become
unsafe ineffective and this is a choice
it's a health of a woman and health of a
mother or the person who's carrying it
so this to me is a medical decision and
if somebody said the diabetic medication
cannot be used anymore I wouldn't be
able to live so it's similarly like that
it's in terms of it's a medically
necessity or
medically needed it's it's not when not
talking about willy-nilly so if that is
the decision between the provider and
the person why should we take that into
a legislative body and with that I
would strongly support the OTP of this
thank you
representative any other uh
withdraw any other
comments seeing no other hands the
motion on the floor is uh ought to pass
OTP on
hcr1 um Madame clerk when you're ready
uh we'll run the role on
that
okay
hcr1 representative Rollins no
Representative lungren no representative
Boyd no Representative levit no
representative Melvin no Representative
gagy no representative culcom
no representative Connor no
representative Manion no representative
Rong yes representative Mass Milla yes
representative manuti yes representative
Carrie yes representative Gallagher yes
representive Judy we Madam representive
Lloyd yes representive Lane yes
representive Sebert yes representative
philio
yes and the chair chair votes no
okay Groundhog
Day 10 to 10 10 to 10 okay Groundhog Day
it is uh yes uh Madam uh Mademoiselle
researcher we will run an itl look for
an itl motion uh same as the last uh 10
to 10 uh the OTP failed we need a u a
subsequent uh
motion um which I can make I I I'll move
itl on HCR
11 is there a second second second from
representative
Gagney um I have nothing to add uh to
what I've already said or that's already
been said uh represent
gagy uh any
h no seeing none uh the current motion
is itl inexpedient to leg legislate on
hcr1 when you're ready Madam
Clerk
all right
itl representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative Boyd yes representative
levit I representative Melvin yes
representative gagy yes representative
ccom
yes getting it um representative Connor
yes representative Manion yes uh
representative rung no representative
Mass Miller no Representative manuti no
representative KY no representative
Gallagher no representative Judy no
Madam representative Lloyd no
representative Lane no representative
Sebert no Representative philio no and
the chair chair votes yes on itl
Groundhog Day 10 to 10 okay 10 to 10 I
will do the uh report one report uh
representative Sebert would you be doing
the other
one okay and we do need to uh we have a
few reports we need to confirm so on
that one uh hcr1 representative Sebert
and I will be doing reports on
hr19 uh myself and represent Philly will
be doing reports on
hcr9 uh that uh represent Manion who
made the motion uh would be doing a
report is and there is uh was there a a
Minority Report on
hcr9 uh we don't have one at this time
we may not have one so man uh
representative Manion on that uh on hcr8
representative Manion and uh again
I unless I hear differently uh later
today we we won't have a Minority Report
unless someone wants to write one uh
um
uh
okay was that eight or nine repres cber
oh okay okay fine uh thank you so uh
minority reports uh from uh
representative seabird on both of those
majority reports on both of those uh
from representative Manion uh the other
ones are all on
consent uh last housekeeping item uh
folks uh we will this committee will
reconvene a week from today uh we have
three measures plus uh the one we recess
so it'll be four measures plus uh exact
next Friday and don't forget we have the
1 SB uh Senate Bell uh on Monday the
12th and we also will have guest
speakers uh that day as well uh before
we close uh anything for the good of the
order as they
say uh on Monday
oh uh Sunday evening at 1800 if you
could email them to me by that time 6 pm
thank you representative sa much obliged
and represent Manion I know I know I can
depend on you okay we will see everybody
uh down the road thank
you thank
you